ja ich dachte mir ich komme spontan und ja heute gibt es nichts freiwilliges das
kann ich heute sagen weil ich soll ist 3 hat modus so anstrengend heute ich habe
heute vier stunden oder viereinhalb stunden auf der arbeit versucht nicht
alleine muss ich sagen ja aber ist ja auch egal also wir haben viereinhalb
stunden versucht irgendwelche helm chart templates zu fixen die der
hersteller verkackt hat das ist unglaublich was im business und
enterprise umfeld für mist ausgeliefert wird er sich das mal vorstellen die
kriegen 1000 euro schaffen es nicht ein installer zu bauen
was heißt installer den chart zu bauen den installer zu bauen ja so kompliziert
ist es eigentlich auch nicht ist wahnsinn
sich hin naja bin gerade umstellen von 130 nebenstellen nebenstellen klingt nach
telefon oder ach nee auf neues vpn okay nicht telefon aber was nennt man dann
noch neben stellen wenn ich telefon weißt du meinst du zu außendienst
standorte oder sowas niederlassungen so was in der richtung
das stimmt wohl ja ist tatsächlich so ein bisschen ähnlich leute freut ihr euch
auf diablo 4
Ich glaube, man kann ja morgen schon, wenn man vorbestellt hat, ich weiß noch nicht genau, also ehrlich gesagt, ich war sehr enttäuscht von Diablo 3.
Und die letzten Jahre über hat Blizzard ja auch ziemlich verschissen.
Die haben es geschafft, dass ich als riesen Diablo-Fan nicht mehr gehypt bin.
Aber was ich bis jetzt gelesen habe, von Refuse, die es schon gibt, soll Diablo 4 wohl echt ganz gut geworden sein.
Wobei ich ja auf die ganzen Refuse immer nicht allzu viel gebe, wenn es um das Thema Langzeit-Motivation geht.
Leute, ich brauche mal ein bisschen was zackigeres, sonst raste ich, drehe ich durch heute.
Ja, wunderbar, irgendwas.
Ja, also wie gesagt.
Wie gesagt, auf die ganzen Refuse kann man, was Langzeit-Motivation angeht, eh nicht allzu viel geben.
Also ich muss sagen, ich persönlich mag tatsächlich auch nach Jahrzehnten immer noch die GameStar-Refuse am besten.
Die decken sich meistens so grob mit dem, was ich über irgendwelche Games denke.
Natürlich gibt es da auch ein paar Reihenfälle, aber das geht schon ganz gut klar.
Aber für so Langzeitsachen kann man eigentlich bei den ganzen Refuse immer nicht wirklich...
...sich wirklich drauf verlassen und ich denke...
...gibt halt die einen Leute, die einfach mal wieder Diablo-Kampagne durchspielen wollen, Diablo bashen und dann ist gut.
Und es gibt halt andere, die erhoffen sich ein Game, was sie jetzt irgendwie die nächsten Jahre über immer mal wieder spielen können oder teilweise Monate durchgängig.
Das muss ich halt tatsächlich langfristig zeigen und man muss halt auch mal gucken...
...ob sich Blizzard nicht noch irgendeine Monetarisierungsstrategie da aus dem Ärmel schüttelt, die einem...
...nicht gefällt.
Ausbildung, Suche, Läufe bei dir. Heute Absage halten.
Echt? Es gibt noch sowas wie Absagen?
Ich dachte, die nehmen aktuell einfach jeden...
Na gut, Ausbildung. Achso, Ausbildung. Ja gut, das suckt natürlich.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie es mit der Activision-Blizzard-Übernahme von Microsoft aussieht.
Das letzte war ja so nach dem Motto...
...Aufsicht bei den Amis muss noch zustimmen. Dann hat die Aufsicht bei den Amis gesagt, ach nee, so geil finden sie das doch nicht.
Unter diesen und diesen Gesichtspunkten, jetzt müssen sie ja noch irgendwas machen.
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht...
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was da rausgekommen ist.
Der UK juckt die nicht.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, was da rausgekommen ist, aber ich denke mal, das läuft immer noch.
Und mittlerweile muss ich fast sagen, so blöd es klingt...
...und Microsoft ist ja nun wirklich einfach...
Ich meine, es kann mir keiner sagen, dass ich irgendwie großer Microsoft-Fan bin, ja?
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, viele...
...also gerade Blizzard...
...die haben ja wirklich...
Ich frage mich, was die auf ihrer BlizzCon machen wollten.
Oder was die auf ihrer BlizzCon machen...
Dieses Jahr ist wieder eine BlizzCon.
Ich weiß nicht, was die da zeigen wollen.
Gras beim Wachsen zugucken, oder wie?
Die haben ja eigentlich...
Na gut, Diablo 4 können sie jetzt ein bisschen was zeigen, ja, okay.
Und neue Projekte, ich bin ja mal skeptisch, ob da irgendwas kommt.
Vielleicht gibt es ja noch einen PvE-Modus für Overwatch 3 jetzt bald.
Wird Zeit, sie könnten...
Vom Entwicklungszyklus wird es passen.
Sie kündigen Overwatch 3 mit PvE an.
Ja, ansonsten bin ich mal gespannt, ob da irgendwas Nennenswertes kommt.
Ansonsten, ich glaube, es wäre gar nicht so schlecht, wenn Microsoft da mal ein bisschen frischen Wind reinbringt.
Allerdings darf man halt nicht vergessen, ganz ehrlich, Leute, man lässt sich da immer so hinreißen dazu.
Oh ja, die bringen jetzt frischen Wind rein, dann kommen wieder gute Games.
Microsoft ist das auch in Wirklichkeit alles scheißegal.
Solange der Rubel rollt, ist Microsoft auch happy.
Also die sind nicht...
Die...
So...
Das ist...
Man muss sich jetzt nicht davon erhoffen, dass die irgendwie die Gameserien retten, die einem am Herzen liegen.
Das kannst du...
Kannst knicken.
Ich meine, guck mal.
Wann haben die Bethesda übernommen?
Wann war denn das?
Oder CeniMax, muss man ja eigentlich sagen.
Ja, vor ungefähr...
Ungefähr 2 Jahren.
Und vom neuen Elder Scrolls hat man immer noch nichts gehört.
Ich meine, das Einzige, was du gehört hast von Elder Scrolls 6 war, vor, keine Ahnung, 5 Jahren oder so, mal den Schriftzug Elder Scrolls 6 und so und das Main Theme 3 Töne.
Fertig.
Also ob da irgendwas zu...
Zumindest habe ich jetzt in letzter Zeit nichts mehr davon gehört.
Nö.
Ich bin mal gespannt.
Was ist bald?
Also die BlizzCon ist im November.
Ach, das Xbox Showcase.
Also bevor Elder Scrolls 6 kommt, kommt tatsächlich Skyrim noch für Fitness-Tracker oder sowas.
Ja, gehe ich auch von aus.
Ich meine, Skyrim wird für jede Plattform kommen, für die es noch nicht da ist, bevor Elder Scrolls 6 rauskommt.
Ja, für Drucker, für Schwangerschaftstests, für Etikettenprinter.
Alles.
Die Übernahme scheitert ja meistens nicht, weil die nicht miteinander können, sondern weil irgendwelche Behörden sagen...
Sie sehen da zu viel, ja, einseitig in dem Markt.
Ja, ansonsten, ob die miteinander können oder nicht, das geht denen doch am Arsch vorbei.
Also ob die EU da was dagegen hat, weiß ich nicht.
Ich weiß, dass die Ami...
Diese Aufsichtsbehörde bei den Amis hat was dagegen.
Gegen die Activision Blizzard.
Äh, nicht Activision Blizzard.
Gegen die Microsoft Activision Blizzard Übernahme.
Weiß aber nicht, was da da aktuell ist.
Was da da aktuell zustande ist.
Ich habe schon ein paar Tage nicht mehr geguckt.
Ich glaube nicht, dass da jemand groß getan hat.
Äh, Eclipse schreibt, ich muss Microsoft aber in ihren C-Sharp .NET Projekten gut loben.
Finde auf ihr...
Ey, muss man sagen, also .NET generell, also seitdem sie .NET neu entwickelt haben, ist das sehr angenehm da drin zu programmieren.
Auch Visual Studio Code ist nice.
Vieles, was Microsoft macht, ist nice.
Allerdings vieles auch scheiße.
Windows vorne weg.
Also, es gibt viele Sachen, die mich aufregen.
Bei Microsoft.
Aber Microsoft hat auch...
Microsoft macht auch gute Sachen.
Ich finde, bei Microsoft merkt man extrem, dass es zwar eine Firma ist, unter dem...
Also, unter diesem Microsoft Namen.
Aber intern total viele unterschiedliche Küppchen geben.
Die so alle bisschen ihr Ding machen.
Bin ich ein VTuber?
Ja.
Obviously.
Ich bin VTuber.
Ich bewege mich nur gerade nicht, deswegen ist die Katze so ruhig.
Was steht heute an?
Versuche nicht einzuschlafen.
Sieben Stunden QuickMuffs.
Oh, nicht schlecht.
Bekommt ihr auch die absurdesten Jobangebote auf LinkedIn und Co.?
Zeig mal eins.
Box, Box, Rocks.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Oh, gut.
Ich glaube, du bist das erste Mal in den zweiten Monat da.
Schön, dass du deinen Weg hergefunden hast.
Ich vermute mal, du kommst von YouTube.
Oder?
Kommst du von YouTube?
Oder hast du hier auf Twitch das Ganze gefunden?
.
Bilde mir ein.
Ich habe dich schon mal auf YouTube irgendwo in den Comments gesehen.
Nee, also ich habe ja keinen privaten LinkedIn Account.
Ich glaube, ich bin so ziemlich der einzige Zufallstreffer.
Okay, dann habe ich mich vertan.
Ich glaube, ich bin da so ziemlich der einzige, der im IT-Sektor tätig ist und keinen privaten LinkedIn Account hat.
Wobei, naja, kann man nicht so sagen.
Ich habe einen Fake LinkedIn Account mit einem Anime-Bild drin.
Und die haben sie nicht gelöscht.
Aber ich habe da auch ewig nicht mehr reingeguckt.
Und keine Ahnung.
Weiß ich nicht, was es da so gibt.
Aber ich weiß von meinem Kollege, der bekommt immer irgendwelche komischen Headhunter-Anfragen auf LinkedIn.
Immer noch.
Obwohl er mittlerweile sogar drin steht, dass er wieder einen Job hat und alles.
Und da ist so viel Schwachsinn dabei.
Das stimmt.
Ja.
Ja, das hat er auch erzählt.
PowerShell macht Spaß, bin von Badge...
Ja, gut.
Ja, okay.
Ich glaube, anstelle von Badge macht alles Spaß.
Sogar Whistle Basic in Office.
Macht Spaß gegen Badge.
PowerShell ist nice.
Allerdings finde ich, ist PowerShell eine ziemlich miese Shell zum drinnen arbeiten.
PowerShell ist für Automatisierungssachen nice.
Aber täglich quasi nur in PowerShell meine Arbeit erledigen möchte ich auch nicht.
Da benutze ich lieber meine Linux ZSH oder meinetwegen auch Bash.
Also auf PowerShell habe ich keinen Bock.
Ich hatte auch noch nie das Verlangen, ehrlich gesagt.
Auf dem Linux System PowerShell nachzuinstallieren.
Das geht ja.
Wissen ja auch einige nicht.
Also PowerShell ist ja mittlerweile lauffähig unter Linux und Windows und ehrlich gesagt
wahrscheinlich auch MacOS.
Ich weiß es gar nicht.
Aber ich kenne niemanden, der PowerShell unter Linux macht.
Warum auch?
Ich habe aber gehört bei mir auf der Arbeit, wollen sie jetzt Microsoft SQL unter Linux
laufen lassen.
Als erstes da dachte ich mir auch, Alter.
Also nicht, dass es schlechter wäre, Microsoft SQL unter Linux laufen zu lassen als unter Windows.
Das Blöde daran ist bloß, dass sich dann Linux Leute drum kümmern müssen.
Und wenn das schön weiterläuft unter Windows, dann haben wir es wenigstens von der Backe.
Ich suche keinen neuen Job.
Das ist richtig.
Okay, gibt es immer noch Probleme bei Microsoft und Activision.
Ja, mach das mal.
Also ganz ehrlich, wenn du die Auswahl hast, was zu programmieren im Batch oder in Visual
Basic, dann würde ich es auf jeden Fall in Visual Basic machen, weil ich meine Visual
Basic ist immerhin noch was, was als Programmiersprache gedacht ist.
Ja, nice.
Gut, ich meine, wenn du was haben willst, könntest du es ja auch aktualisieren.
Aber das meiste ist eh Schrott.
Ich habe gesehen, bei uns auf der Arbeit gibt es zwei neue Stellen, die ausgeschrieben sind.
Ich sage euch jetzt nicht, welche genau, sonst könnt ihr googeln und wisst genau, wo ich arbeite.
Und habe ich jetzt gleich erst mal zwei Ex-Kollegen geschickt von der alten Arbeit.
Mal gucken, ob die da Bock drauf haben, können sich bewerben.
Ich glaube, ich habe da mittlerweile schon so viele vermittelt.
Also wirklich vermittelt habe ich ja nur einen.
Aber ich habe schon öfters mal angemerkt, ich kenne da jemanden, die müssen mir ein bisschen mehr als die normale Prämie geben, glaubt mich.
Die sollten mir auch sowas geben, wenn ich da einen vermittle, was so ein Headhunter bekommt.
Irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Hälfte vom ersten Jahresgehalt oder sowas, easy.
Wie viel Prämie gibt es?
Ja, so um die 2000 Euro.
Es ist weniger, es ist weniger, es ist eine Ecke weniger.
Ich würde es dir aber nicht genau sagen, weil vielleicht kann man das googeln und finde das dann.
Ja, das ist so ein Mitarbeiter, wer ein Mitarbeiterprogramm.
Die meisten Leute, die würde ich persönlich sogar ganz ohne Prämie empfehlen.
Weil bis jetzt, also ich bin jetzt zwei Monate, sind das wieder Linux-Jobs.
Auch, auch, ja, es ist Linux, Netzwerk, Cloud, alles mögliche dabei.
Ja, und die Leute, die Leute würde ich wahrscheinlich auch ohne jegliche Prämie vermitteln.
Also erstens, finde ich es jetzt nach zwei Monaten ganz nice da, sodass ich es den anderen empfehlen würde.
Und allein schon, weil sie dort sogar eine ganze Ecke mehr verdienen als im alten Job.
Ich weiß ja, was die ungefähr gekriegt haben.
Und auch super reinpassen würden, würde ich die vermitteln.
Aber gut, die müssen erstmal wollen.
Ich habe denen vorhin mal eine Message geschrieben über das Handy, aber es hat noch keiner, hat sich noch keiner gerührt bisher von denen.
Insofern, so.
Kannst du inzwischen arbeiten oder ist dein Laptop immer noch zugenagelt?
Ja, ich kann arbeiten, aber mein Laptop ist immer noch zugenagelt.
Ich habe eine eigene Linux-VM, auf der ich root bin.
Ich habe quasi auf meinem Notebook bloß ein Terminal im Fullscreen, das geht.
Aber schön ist es trotzdem nicht.
Ich muss da auch ein bisschen mehr meckern, dass man mal, dass alle mitbekommen, wie painstchampig das ist.
Du verwendest PowerShell unter Linux?
Ja, okay.
Okay, fürs Administrieren von irgendwelchen Microsoft-Sachen kann ich es verstehen.
Ja.
Okay, das leuchtet ja ein, ne?
Das...
Verstehe ich schon.
Allerdings, da benutzt du es ja auch quasi für was, wo es irgendwie so ein bisschen ein Alleinstellungsmerkmal hat.
Ich meinte jetzt halt einfach PowerShell unter Linux für so tägliche Adminarbeit.
Das wäre mir nix.
Da bleibe ich bei den klassischen Shells.
Einfach, einfach.
Einfach auch ein bisschen wegen der Gewöhnung.
Und, weiß ich, da habe ich alles.
Ich kann die ganzen Linux-Tools ordentlich benutzen.
Ich brauche kein find-str-v-irgendwas, wie das in PowerShell ist.
PowerShell ist vom Ansatz her cool.
Dadurch, dass du nicht Text pipst, sondern .NET-Objekte pipst und dann auf Properties zugreifen kannst.
Ganz ehrlich, aber mir ist eine einfache Shell mit Text raus und Text rein immer noch am liebsten.
Zum täglichen interaktiven Arbeiten.
Ja, für solche Sachen leuchtet es mir irgendwo ein.
Danke für den Sub.
Hogu.
Erster Monat.
Das ist ja extremly...
Nice.
Ne.
Also, bei uns gibt es...
Bei uns gibt es...
Wobei, 32 Tage Urlaub würden sie wahrscheinlich noch mit sich reden lassen.
Aber 100% Homeoffice wirst du bei uns nicht kriegen.
Ich bin trotzdem gewechselt, weil es immer noch eine wahnsinns Verbesserung ist.
Und zwar bei meinem alten Job haben sie ja angefangen, während der Corona-Zeit, habe ich euch schon oft genug erzählt, aber nur mal kurz.
Während der Corona-Zeit haben sie ja da angefangen, Homeoffice und so.
Wir haben jetzt supertolle Regelungen.
Und sobald Corona halbwegs vorbei war, haben sie diese ganzen Regelungen wieder eingestampft.
Und...
Ohne irgendwie großartig was zu sagen.
Also, das war dann am Ende.
Jetzt ist es aktuell so, bei der alten Arbeit, habe ich letztens von einem Ex-Kollege gehört, die wollen, dass die Leute wieder quasi jeden Tag kommen.
Und es gibt nur maximal einen Tag die Woche Homeoffice, in Ausnahmefällen zwei.
Wenn man ganz gute Begründungen hat.
Und das ist halt echt nicht das, was ich mir vorgestellt habe, da quasi...
Ach ja, und sie machen auch keinen Unterschied zwischen Teilzeitarbeitenden und Vollzeitarbeitenden.
Also sprich, ich mit 80% hätte genauso oft hingemusst, wie einer, der 100% arbeitet.
Und das haben sie wirklich richtig beschissen gemacht.
Deswegen finden die im alten Unternehmen, wo ich gearbeitet habe, auch niemand.
Das habe ich letztens auch wieder gehört.
Da wird gefragt im Vorstellungsgespräch von den Bewerbern, wie sieht es bei Ihnen mit Homeoffice-Regelungen aus?
Und dann sagen die, ja, gibt es nicht.
Und dann sagt er, tschüss, dann gehe ich woanders hin.
Ja.
Und deswegen bin ich auch gewechselt.
Das war eines der Hauptgründe, warum ich gewechselt bin.
Und wir haben aktuell nur die Vorgabe, und das ist tatsächlich die einzige Vorgabe, die existiert,
dass wir im Durchschnitt, über einen Monat gesehen, einmal die Woche da sein sollen.
Theoretisch könnte man jetzt argumentieren, ja gut, bei mir mit 80%, ja, wenn sie mal eine Woche nicht so ist, ist auch nicht wild.
Juckt aber auch keinen.
Ich meine, viele von den Leuten bei mir kommen sogar nur alle zwei Wochen.
Also insofern, eine Woche da sein, drei Wochen mobil, das könntest du machen.
Das könntest du machen.
Klar, manche Teams haben solche Sachen, wie einmal mittwochs ist Teamrunde, wird gerne gesehen, wenn man da ist.
Aber ist in meinem Team zum Beispiel nicht so.
Bei mir ist es vollkommen frei, welcher Tag man kommt.
Und ob du mal eine Woche daheim bleibst und dann zwei Tage da bist, oder so, interessiert keinen.
Es nervt, es hat mich noch nicht einer genervt damit.
Also, die scheinen das wirklich ernst zu nehmen, ja.
Die haben mir das gesagt, so ist es.
Ich halte mich da dran.
Und es gibt keine Probleme und keinen Sturz, ja.
Also, Geld wirst du easy kriegen bei uns.
Allerdings 100% Homeoffice wird es nicht geben.
Okay, 32 Tage Urlaub kann ich dir nicht sagen.
Also, standardmäßig nicht, aber vielleicht, wenn du das verhandelst, warum nicht.
Wenn es halt was ist, musst du händeringend Leute suchen.
Der Juniorenmarkt ist etwas schwieriger.
Also, bei uns finden die nirgendwo Leute.
Die finden bei uns keine Seniorleute.
Die finden uns bei uns auch keine Einzelne.
Die finden uns bei uns auch keine Einsteiger und normalen Leute.
Die finden gar nichts.
Ich habe letztens gesehen, wir haben, glaube ich, insgesamt fünf Adminstellen oder so offen.
Und, nee, mehr, mehr, mehr Adminstellen.
Ich glaube, sieben.
Ich glaube, alleine vier oder fünf Seniorstellen haben wir offen.
Und noch ein paar Juniors in dem Fall gibt es bei uns nicht.
Das heißt dann halt einfach ganz normal, wie die Berufsbezeichnung, die sie suchen.
Und die sind schon ewig offen.
Da bewirbt sich einfach keiner drauf.
Oder, ja, vielleicht bewirbt sich ab und zu mal einer und die taugen gar nichts.
Weiß nicht.
Also, die finden überhaupt niemand.
Ja, schick mal rüber.
Ja, schick.
Darkseid, schick rüber.
Kenn ich gar nicht.
Was für einen Application Launcher benutzt du unter i3?
Du meinst das hier, vermute ich mal.
Moment.
Ja, ist gut.
Ich guck gleich.
Du meinst nicht meine Leiste?
Sondern du meinst das Popup-Ding, ne?
Also quasi.
Du meinst das hier.
Wo man auch hier unten noch Fenster suchen kann und Emojis einfügen kann.
Das nennt sich Rofi oder Roffi oder wie auch immer.
Rofi wahrscheinlich.
GitHub.
Da musst du aber einiges customizen.
Standardmäßig das Ding.
Sehr gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Sehr gewöhnungsbedürftig aus, auf jeden Fall.
Guck mal, gab schon lange keinen Release mehr.
Kann man aber auch extrem customizen, das Ding.
D-Menu ist auch vollkommen okay.
Also, wenn dir das reicht.
Man muss es ja nicht übertreiben, als sein muss, ne?
Was ist eigentlich mit deinen alten Dot-Files im Arch-Linux-Report?
Die gibt es noch.
Guck mal.
Dot-Files.
Und dann gehst du hier unter Old-Dot-Files.
Habe ich wenigstens mal gescheit benannt.
Da hast du die noch.
Da gibt es auch noch hier die I3-Status-Rust-Config.
Kann aber sein, dass die mit der aktuellen Version gar nicht mehr geht.
Hört sich nicht so an, als gibt es kaum noch Leute, die bei deinem alten Laden arbeiten.
Das ist korrekt.
Also, es sind sehr viele gegangen.
Und viele, die von denen da sind, wo ich jetzt gehört habe, sind quasi kurz vorm Abhauen.
Ja.
Da ging es, beziehungsweise geht es richtig, richtig den Bach runter.
Und wisst ihr, was ich Witziges gehört habe?
Nachdem sie ja ein komplettes Team dort zumachen wollen, schwebt ihnen vor, dass die Arbeit, die das Team gemacht hat, jetzt von...
Also, die hatten da so ein 24-7-Team.
Ich habe immer gesagt, das ist der Support.
Das stimmt nicht.
Das war nicht wirklich der Support.
Das war eher so eine Art Operations Center.
Also, die waren 24-7 im Schichtbetrieb da.
Haben Systeme überwacht.
Haben eskaliert, wenn Meldungen gekommen sind.
Haben erste Analyse gemacht, wenn was kaputt gegangen ist.
Haben Wartungsarbeiten nachts durchgeführt und sowas.
Ja.
Das war eher ein Operations Center.
Ich habe die immer Support genannt.
Ne, nicht wirklich Services.
Aber es ist eigentlich so...
Ich glaube, offiziell heißen die auch Operations Center.
So.
Und das wollen sie dicht machen.
Und wisst ihr, warum sie das dicht machen?
Das ist eigentlich ganz witzig.
Weil es keine Leute finden.
Und sie die Leute, die dort gearbeitet haben...
So schlecht behandelt haben, dass sie abgehauen sind.
Und jetzt können sie sagen, wir können den Schichtbetrieb nicht aufrecht erhalten, weil uns die Leute wegrennen.
So als wären die Leute, die abhauen, die Bösen.
Hättet ihr euch angestrengt, dann hättet ihr neue Leute gefunden.
Die alten Leute wären euch nicht abgehauen.
Zumindest machen sie da jetzt dicht.
Und sie haben einen Dienstleister händeringend gesucht, der die Arbeiten übernimmt.
Und jetzt haben sie wohl...
Also, wie gesagt, ich höre das immer noch um drei Ecken.
Von dem Laden, wo ich gearbeitet habe.
Und jetzt haben sie einen Dienstleister gefunden, der sich dazu bereit erklärt hat, das zu übernehmen.
Und jetzt kam halt im Nachhinein raus, dass der Dienstleister nichts macht, außer Ticket-Handling.
Also das einzige, was der Dienstleister macht ist, Monitoring meldet, Service, Applikation, Server, was auch immer hat Probleme.
Und dann...
Ja, keine Ahnung, machen die ein Störungsticket.
Und...
Vielleicht, wenn es eine Eskalationsliste gibt, versuchen die nachts einen anzurufen.
Fertig, das war's.
Good luck, have fun.
Ist der Dienstleister Bechtle?
Ne, aber ich glaube, die haben es sich auch angeguckt.
JSD LAN, dankeschön für den Sub.
Oh.
Ne, also, das geht da total den Bach runter.
Und der Dienstleister wird das halt alles...
Ich sag dir nicht, welche das ist.
Der Dienstleister wird das alles super nach Vorschrift machen.
Wenn da irgendwie ein Monitoring falsch konfiguriert ist und nachts 3.000 Notifications schickt, dann machen die 3.000 Tickets auf.
Die rufen 3.000 mal an und die schicken auch, wenn es sein muss, 3.000 SMS-Notifications, weil es so in den SLA's drinnen steht.
Da kennen die nix.
So ist es halt, wenn du Dienstleister hast, die sich halt nicht dafür interessieren.
Beziehungsweise die ist halt einfach stur nach...
Aha, so ist es geregelt, so machen wir das.
Es hat schon durchaus seinen Sinn, sowas im Haus zu haben.
Die haben das ja extra aufgebaut vor ein paar Jahren, jetzt wird es wieder abgeschafft.
Also richtig bescheuert.
Und sind selbst dran schuld.
Denen rennen halt nicht nur dort die Leute weg.
Ich weiß, dass in meinem alten Team ganz viele Leute...
Also, ich bin ja schon weg.
Noch einer ist Ende des Monats weg.
Im anderen noch mehr, egal.
Zumindest ganz viele andere haben auch keinen Bock mehr.
Was machst du so im Daily Business?
Ich kann dir sagen, was ich heute gemacht hab, zum Beispiel, wenn du willst.
Pixel Black Kids.
Ich kann dir sagen, was ich heute gemacht hab.
Heute habe ich viereinhalb Stunden versucht, ein Helm Install Script, beziehungsweise halt einen Helm Chart...
Versuch mal kurz zu erklären, wer das nicht kennt.
Helm ist ein Installer oder ein Package Manager für Kubernetes.
Also, wenn du eine Anwendung in deinem Kubernetes starten willst, dann ist es meistens so, dass die Hersteller...
Also, egal was ihr benutzt, ja.
Hersteller liefern in der Regel irgendwelche Packages mit.
Oder irgendwelche Install Scripts mit.
Und im Kubernetes Umfeld liefern die Helm Charts, beziehungsweise Helm Templates mit.
Das ist quasi ein Installer.
Könnte man so sagen.
Und von der Idee her ist das so, du musst halt nichts machen.
Außer, dass du wie bei einem Installer einstellst so, welche Ports sollen die Anwendung benutzen.
Welche Repos sollen die benutzen.
Welche URLs sollen sie für den Ingress...
Also, du hast so einen Values File.
Da gibst du an.
Wie du die Anwendung einrichten willst.
Und dann lässt du Helm das quasi deployen in deinen Kubernetes Cluster.
Und dann unter der Haube sind das halt Go Templates.
Und die Werte, die du halt in deinem Installer gesetzt hast, werden dann an der richtigen Stelle eingesetzt.
Und es kommen Config Files raus, die man in Kubernetes supplyen kann.
Dafür ist Helm so.
Und ich habe heute viereinhalb Stunden versucht, mit noch drei anderen Leuten komplett verbuggte, ungetestete Helm installen zu können.
Helm Install Packages vom Hersteller zu deployen.
Und wir sind zu dem Schluss gekommen, als wir angefangen haben in den Template Files rum zu wursten, in denen man eigentlich nichts machen muss.
Ja, weil wie gesagt, das ist ja eigentlich ein Installer.
Die Templates macht der Hersteller.
Sind wir zu dem Schluss gekommen, die haben den Kram nie getestet.
Ja, die Secrets heißen falsch.
Die Namensauflösung ist falsch.
Komplett ungetesteter Shit, den sie uns da geschickt haben.
Das habe ich heute versucht viereinhalb Stunden zu fixen.
Zwischendurch war ich nochmal kurz auf meiner Teamrunde.
Und dann war ich noch was essen und das war es eigentlich.
Also mit viereinhalb Stunden den Kram angeguckt, das hat mir auch echt gereicht.
So ein richtiger Crap, Mann.
Dann hatte ich noch ein Projekt Daily von einer Viertelstunde.
Ein Weekly Termin, so was gibt es Neues.
Kurz Teamrunde.
Und dann heute Mittag nochmal irgend so ein Startprojekt.
Status, Status Meeting.
Also wirklich gemacht habe ich nichts.
Wir haben versucht die Installer, die Helm Install Packages zu fixen, dass sie gehen.
Wir haben es im Endeffekt allerdings nicht hinbekommen.
Wobei ich sagen muss, wir wären nichts weit davon entfernt gewesen.
Also wir waren noch nie so nah dran, es zum Laufen zu bekommen.
Aber wir haben gesagt, es ist nicht unser Job, den kaputten Installer des Herstellers zu fixen.
Sondern wir melden das an den Hersteller.
Dass sie eben ihre Installer fixen.
Dass sie eben ihre Installer ganz machen sollen.
Also das wäre bei uns möglich, ja.
Das heißt du kannst, ja, kannst du machen.
Wie gesagt, sofern das, also bei mir im Team wäre das möglich, bei anderen weiß ich nicht.
Wahrscheinlich.
Okay.
Karriere, was?
Milch und Zucker?
Ist das G-Baid?
Was ist das?
Milch und Zucker?
Ach, das ist ein Personalvermittler, oder was?
Milch und Zucker.
Geiler Name.
Okay, was soll ich mir jetzt angucken?
Das hier.
Systemadministrator Linux.
Männlich, weiß.
Keine Ahnung.
Milch und Zucker steht für Entwicklung von...
Musik passt gut dazu.
Also, Milch und Zucker steht für Entwicklung von Talent Acquisition und Talent...
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, ob man das richtig ausspricht.
Und Talentmanagementlösung.
Ach, ne, die entwickeln so Recruitingportale oder sowas.
Unsere eigene Recruitingsoftware.
150 helle Köpfe und 300 sprühende Hirn...
Okay.
Die werben damit, dass sie extremely pfeifert sind.
Sprühende Hirn sorgen dafür, dass unsere Kunden die passende IT-Lösung für Recruitingprozesse bekommen.
Im Spangar zwischen Standard und hochindividuell.
Menschlicher Intuition und künstlicher Intelligenz.
Emot...
Ach du...
Alter, was...
Okay.
Aber das sagt ja noch nix.
Das sagt ja noch nix.
300 Hirnhälften, also 150 Hirne.
Ja gut, 150 Hirne in 150 Köpfen.
Es sei denn, jemand hat mehr als eine, zwei Hirnhälften.
Okay, also.
Zeig mal her.
So.
Äh, Frage Darkseid.
Schickst du das, weil es besonders blöd ist, was jetzt gleich kommt?
Oder weil du dich da bewerben willst?
Egal.
Sag's nicht.
Wir gucken's uns an.
Weil bis jetzt...
Bis jetzt sieht es ja vollkommen in Ordnung aus.
Ein ziemlicher cringe Intro-Satz.
Aber gut, man muss halt irgendwas machen, wo die Leute vielleicht sich...
Wo man zumindest denkt, die Leute interessiert sich für.
Also, darum geht's.
Du bist ein Bind...
Als was entwirft...
Okay, Admin.
Klassischer, klassischer Admin.
Das, wo seit den letzten zehn Jahren die Leute erzählen, Administrator stirbt aus.
Find ich lustig, ja.
Ich mein, klar.
Theoretisch ist es nicht mehr so, dass es...
Also, es gibt halt noch viel mehr als nur Administration.
Früher hast du quasi geguckt, okay, IT-Infrastruktur, Admin, Admin, Admin, Admin, Admin.
Was anderes gab's da nicht.
Heute hast du halt schon noch ein bisschen mehr.
Du hast viel im DevOps-Bereich, Cloud-Engineering-Bereich.
Was, ach, was noch alles gibt.
Aber Admins gibt's immer noch.
Also, dieses ganze, oh, Hilfe, bald gibt's keine Admins mehr.
Fand ich schon immer sehr merkwürdig, wie man auf die Idee kommt.
Weil ich mein, wer soll den Kram im Endeffekt betreiben?
Auch in der Cloud.
Ich mein, du hast auch Infrastruktur in der Cloud, die administriert werden muss.
Es ist ja nicht so, als nur, weil die Sachen jetzt auf einmal nicht beim eigenen Erzherz stehen,
sondern in der Cloud, dass das niemand mehr administrieren muss.
Auf so Ideen kommen nur Leute, die, glaub ich, da mit der...
Mit...
Mit dem Betrieb von Systemen noch nie was zu tun hatten.
Ja, also ich mein, ist klar, dass du immer nur Admins brauchst.
Und das wirst du auch auf lange Zeit...
Auf längere Sicht wird das so bleiben.
Wirst du nicht...
Warum sich da was ändert...
Okay, also gucken wir uns das mal an.
Du bist Bindeglied zwischen unseren Entwicklern und den Produktivsystemen.
Ja gut, klingt ja schon mal sinnvoll für einen Admin.
Als technischer Admin fühlst du dich in Serverkellern.
Und recht, ja, Kellern fühlen wir uns wohl, Leute.
Und Rechenzentren genauso wohl wie bei der täglichen Administrationsüberwachung der Systeme.
Außerdem unterstützt du unsere Entwicklung bei der technischen Umsetzung von Kundenwünschen und Initiativen...
Okay, okay, blablabla.
Also, zeig mal ja.
Installation, Konfiguration, Betreuung von Linux-Systemen.
Ja gut, das würde ich bei einem Systemadministrator Linux auch erwarten.
Vorwie...
Okay, Rocky Linux.
Das sind die ersten, die ich kenne, die live Rocky Linux benutzen.
Also, ihnen bleibt ja nichts anderes übrig, wenn sie was...
Okay, ALMA vielleicht noch.
Ich mein, ihnen bleibt ja nichts anderes übrig, wenn sie...
Red Hat benutzen wollen, allerdings kein Red Hat bezahlen wollen, außer Rocky oder ALMA.
Gibt es eigentlich Scientific Linux noch?
Das war ja auch mal so ein Red Hat...
Red Hat-Clone.
Oracle Linux.
Das Blöde an Oracle Linux ist, ich hab das schon öfters erzählt...
Du kannst kein Oracle Linux verwenden, kostenlos, wenn du Oracle Datenbanken betreibst.
Weil Oracle Datenbanken...
Jetzt, jetzt...
Hört euch...
Hört euch das...
Also...
Saugt das mal in euch auf, was Oracle da wieder für einen Scheiß baut.
Oracle hat eine Lizenzvereinbarung, dass wenn du einen Supportvertrag hast für eines ihrer Produkte und du möchtest ein anderes Produkt von ihnen einsetzen, dann musst du dieses andere Produkt mindestens so lizenzieren, wie das andere, was du schon hast.
Das heißt im Endeffekt, du hast Oracle Datenbanken, du hast Supportvertrag für Oracle Datenbanken.
So und jetzt möchtest du Oracle Linux verwenden.
Kannst du normalerweise kostenlos verwenden.
Wenn du allerdings Oracle Datenbanken hast mit einem Supportvertrag, dann nicht.
Dann musst du jede Oracle Linux Installation mindestens dem gleichen Supportvertrag versichern, wie deine Oracle Datenbanken.
Das heißt, du kannst normalerweise Oracle Linux kostenlos benutzen, aber wenn du einen Supportvertrag mit Datenbanken hast, musst du halt einfach 55 Millionen bezahlen für deine anderen Sachen.
Oracle ist der letzte Drecksladen, was Lizenzen angeht.
Ich kann nicht verstehen, wie irgendjemand ernsthaft entscheidet, Oracle für irgendwas zu benutzen.
Leute, ich muss das mal kurz rüberkopieren, die Stellenanzeige ist mir zu grell.
So ist es viel angenehmer.
Also, die benutzen Rocky Linux.
Okay, verstehe.
Leuchtet ja auch ein, wie gesagt.
Kannst ja nur Rocky oder Alma noch sinnvoll benutzen, wenn du Red Hat benutzen willst, aber kein Red Hat bezahlen willst.
Performance, Capacity und Availability Management.
Okay, alles klar.
Ähm...
Anpassung und Erstellung von Automatisierungsvorgängen, Ansible und Automatisierungsvorgängen.
Klingt auch sehr klassisch, System-Admin-mäßig.
Da ist der Übergang zwischen dem, was man so unter DevOps veranschlagt und Admin eher fließend.
Administration der VMware Cluster und SAN.
Okay, die Läden, die ich kenne, die haben eigene Teams.
Sowohl eigene Teams für SAN, als auch eigene Teams für VMware.
Was auch oftmals daran liegt, dass halt Linux-Leute sich nicht zwangsläufig mit SAN und VMware auskennen.
Man muss nämlich mal Fairness halber sagen, sowohl VMware als auch SAN, wenn es eine größere Umgebung ist, das sind beides Wissenschaften für sich.
Also betreibt man eine komplexe VMware-Umgebung, betreibt man eine komplexe SAN-Storage-Infrastruktur, da seid ihr eigentlich ausgelastet genug mit und könnt nicht nebenbei noch euch um alle Linux-Systeme kümmern.
Und umgedreht.
Also...
Je nachdem.
Kommt immer drauf an, wie umfangreich das Ganze ist.
Datensicherung, Backup und Recovery.
Ja, klingt sinnvoll.
Zumindest, dass man sich Gedanken darüber macht, ob man jetzt das eigentliche Backup-System auch administriert.
Weiß man nicht.
Aber wahrscheinlich.
Wenn man auch vor allem mal Cluster und SAN macht, kümmert man sich wahrscheinlich auch um das eigentliche Backup-System.
Okay.
Das bist du.
Als Netzwerk-Administ...
Ja, wie jetzt?
Denkst du, ich wollte Linux-Admin und kein Netzwerk-Administrator?
Ich glaube, das ist ein Copy-Paste.
Ich glaube, das ist ein Copy-Paste-Fehler, oder?
Als Netzwerk-Administrator macht dir so schnell keiner was vor.
Du punktest...
Du punktest durch Erfahrung neu...
Kannst du in deinem Vorstellungsgespräch gleich ansprechen.
Du hast einen Copy-Paste-Fehler entdeckt.
Wobei, das macht keinen guten Eindruck, gleich zu sagen hier.
Aber man kann es ja auch nett ansprechen, so.
Ich glaube, ihr habt euch verschrieben.
Oder sie meinen das tatsächlich synonym, was aber eigentlich keinen Sinn ergibt.
Als Netzwerk-Administrator macht dir so schnell keiner was vor.
Du punktest durch Erfahrung und Neugier.
Du bist gewissenhaft...
Moment.
Gehen.
Du bist gewissenhaft.
Man kann dir blind vertrauen.
Außerdem bist du ein absoluter Teamplayer.
Und hast top...
Was?
Ach, und hast on top die Ausbildung, Erfahrung mit Linux, idealerweise Red Hat, tiefgreifende Kenntnisse von Apache PHP.
Ich habe immer den Eindruck, diese Technologie-Sachen, die die da reinschreiben, sind komplett random.
So komplett...
Ja, lasst uns da einfach mal ein bisschen was reinschreiben.
Apache, weil...
Ich meine, warum sollst du...
Warum sollst du tiefgreifende Kenntnisse mit PHP haben?
Ich meine, du kannst einen YAML-Install MySQL und einen YAML-Install PHP machen.
Und vielleicht auch noch die eine oder andere Datenbank-Migration laufen lassen.
Aber das reicht ja auch.
Aber das...
Gut.
Da muss man aber nicht...
Klar, Silver, her damit.
Da muss man aber nicht so viel drauf geben.
Wie gesagt, oftmals wird das erstellt von irgendwelchen Personalleuten, die ein paar Begriffe noch hingeschmissen bekommen von der Technik und dann irgendwie so ein Best-of draus bauen.
Muss man nicht so viel drauf geben.
Es ist durchaus okay, wenn das da so drinsteht.
Ich meine, kann ja auch durchaus sein, dass sie das hier als ihren, wie man so schön sagt heutzutage, Technologie-Stack benutzen.
Wobei gerade die Apache-PAP-Kombi schon sehr, sehr oldschool ist.
Und...
Also, die Apache-PAP-MySQL-Kombi schon sehr oldschool ist.
Ich meine, nicht, dass es nicht funktionieren würde oder so, aber...
Elasticsearch und Tomcat-Setups.
Verständnis von TCP-IP-Netzwerktechnik, NAT, VPN oder IPsec, Firewalls sowie Docker, Kubernetes...
Ach, Kubernetes auch noch.
Okay.
Ja, gut.
Wie gesagt, ich gehe davon aus, diese Stellenanzeige ist halt mal wieder entstanden.
Die Personalabteilung hat das am Ende geschrieben.
Die hat...
Man hat keine Ahnung von diesen Sachen, die da drinstehen.
Und die Teams oder das Team, was jemand braucht, hat halt ein paar Begriffe hingeschmissen.
Und dann kommt dann so was raus.
Aber ein bisschen Erfahrung damit ist ja heutzutage auch nicht zu viel verlangt.
Weil ganz im Ernst ist...
Ich finde es zwar ein bisschen hart, dass du dich um quasi komplette VMware-Infrastruktur, SAN und um die Niedlungsinfrastruktur kümmern sollst.
Aber man weiß ja nicht, wie groß das ist.
Ich meine, vielleicht meinen die ja auch mit SAN im Endeffekt eine Storage-Kiste, wo du dich alle Schaltjahre mal drauf einladen kannst.
Und VMware-Cluster irgendwie drei Kisten irgendwie in ein paar Racks stehen.
Also...
Virtualisierungstechnik?
Know-how!
Aha, Nagios-Stelz sehe ich hier.
Okay.
Es war mal Nagios.
Es ist mittlerweile, glaube ich, kein Nagios mehr.
Space War.
Gibt es das überhaupt noch?
Ich dachte, das heißt jetzt Satellite, oder?
Das ist so eine Red Hat Web...
Das ist ein Web-Interface für...
Red Hat-basierte Distributionen, wo man zum Beispiel...
Tja, was macht man über Satellite?
Da kann man seine Systeme drin registrieren und Skripts laufen lassen und sowas.
Also, ich kenne keinen, der das noch ernsthaft benutzt.
Also, bei mir auf der aktuellen Arbeit gibt es irgendwo auch noch irgendwo in den Untiefen einen Red Hat Satellite.
Aber ich glaube, so wirklich machen tut damit keiner was.
Was ist die Stellenbeschreibung?
Linux Server Administra...
Äh, nee.
Systemadministrator Linux.
Okay, dann sollst du noch ein bisschen Ahnung von Ansible haben.
Vollkommen okay in der heutigen Zeit.
Ansible ist eigentlich so das Tool schlechthin zur Automatisierung, beziehungsweise zum Einstieg in Infrastructure as Code, wie das die coolen Leute nennen.
Allerdings im Cloud-Umfeld ist es dann tatsächlich eher Terraform.
Und Ansible ist halt das verbreitetste und ich würde auch sagen, meiner zumindest persönlichen Meinung nach, das beste Tool für solche Geschichten, was es aktuell gibt.
Gerade für klassische Linux Server Konfigurationen.
Ansible hat ein paar Negativpunkte, die so Sachen wie beispielsweise Puppet besser können.
Aber dafür kann Ansible alles andere besser.
Also Puppet kann zum Beispiel schöne Tryruns, wo man sieht, was passieren würde.
Dafür ist Ansible so viel angenehmer zu programmieren.
Beziehungsweise kann man das Programmieren nennen.
Ja, ich nenne es mal Programmieren.
Als Puppet.
Meiner Meinung nach.
So.
Docker auch okay.
HAProxy auch vollkommen in Ordnung.
Pacemaker Chorusing.
Boah, das habe ich ja schon lange nicht mal in der Stellenanzeige gelesen.
Zur Erklärung, also wer mal Linux Cluster gebaut hat von Hand, der hat das wahrscheinlich mit Pacemaker und Chorusing gemacht.
Das ist in letzter Zeit weniger angesagt, als noch vor 15 Jahren.
Also die Kombi habe ich schon lange lange nicht gesehen.
Also die Kombi habe ich schon lange lange nicht mehr gelesen.
Ich bin mir aus dem Kopf gar nicht mehr sicher, was für was zuständig ist.
Ich glaube Pacemaker ist für die Keep-Alive-Geschichte zuständig.
So mit IP-Schwenken und sonst was.
Und für was war Chorusing nochmal zuständig?
Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr genau.
Aber ich kenne beides.
Aber schon ewig nicht mal von Hand aufgesetzt und benutzt.
Nee, Keep-Alive.
Keep-Alive ist das zum Umschwenken von IPs.
Pacemaker ist die Geschichte mit...
Ähm...
Erkennen, ob der Node ab oder...
Ach, ich weiß es aus dem Kopf nicht mehr.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr, es ist zu lange her.
Also ohne Scheiß, die Sachen in Kombi, die habe ich zuletzt vor 10 Jahren verwendet.
IP-Tables Shorewall.
Ist das nicht irgendeine Standalone-Linux-Distro?
Ach nee, das ist irgendein Konfigurationstool.
Kennt man das?
Release-Nodes.
Von...
2020.
Okay, auch nicht sonderlich aktuell.
Was ist das?
Ist das irgendein Management-Interface?
Oder...
Monkatos?
Ist das...
Ist das ein bisschen so ein...
Linux-Server...
Konfig-Webinterface?
Die Dinger, die eigentlich keiner verwendet, wenn er noch irgendwie halbwegs bei Verstand ist?
Oh, sieht ja topakt...
Sieht ja topaktuell aus, Alter.
Sieht mir so...
Ja gut, warum nicht?
Und Searchsystem erwünscht.
Sehr gutes Deutsch, C1, gute Englischkenntnisse, B2.
Okay, keine Ahnung, das sind irgendwelche Stufen, wie flüssig man redet.
Ja, klingt doch in Ordnung.
Ist doch passend, ne?
Ich meine, ich kann an allem irgendwie rummeckern, aber im Kurs und Ganzen klingt das doch eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich muss aber sagen, es ist jetzt auch nichts, was mich vom Hocker haut, wo ich denken würde, oh ja, da muss ich mich jetzt umhacken.
Ich suche ja eh nichts Neues.
Sieht sehr 0815 aus, kann aber durchaus was taugen.
Ich glaube, dazu muss man den Laden kennen.
So...
Ja, wie gesagt, das habe ich ja schon geschickt.
Pogu.
Ich bin mittlerweile nicht bei E3-Status Rust, ich bin bei Bumblebee-Status.
Ist das hier.
Hatte jemand Erfahrung, bei einem Dienstleister zu arbeiten? Kann es empfehlen.
In der modernen I.T. Welt sind alles Dienstleister.
Das geht dann so weit.
Das geht dann so weit, dass in einem Team gesprochen wird.
Das ist unser Kunde.
Da stehen die ganzen Manager und Business Leute irgendwie drauf.
Du darfst da nicht mehr sagen.
Ey, die Entwickler wollen wieder komisches Zeug.
Das ist Standard.
Ein bisschen Gezahnke zwischen Entwicklungen und Admins ist ja eigentlich normal.
Die Admins sagen Entwicklerprogrammieren ist scheiß.
Und die Entwickler sagen Alter, warum machen die das alles so kompliziert.
Das ist normal, ein bisschen.
Zumindest stehen die ganzen Manager drauf.
Die wollen, dass man nicht sagt, ey, die Entwickler wollen wieder komisches Zeug.
Die wollen sagen, unser Kunde aus der Entwicklung möchte das und das.
Halte ich mich aber immer nicht dran.
Ich meine, ganz ehrlich, gut, bei meinem neuen Arbeitgeber ist es auch nicht so extrem.
So dieses, ja, wir reden jetzt nur noch von Kunden.
Wir reden jetzt nicht mehr von irgendwie anderer Abteilung.
Das sind alles unsere Kunden.
Das ist irgendeiner, der unbedingt ITIL-Speak einführen will, aber mit der Realität nichts zu tun hat.
Ey, ähm, also ja, ich kann dir aber auch sagen, wie es ist, bei einem Dienstleister zu arbeiten.
Warum habe ich das Erste eigentlich jetzt erzählt?
Ach so, ja, weil ja mittlerweile alles nur noch Dienstleister sind, so laut Management-Gehirnspinseln.
Ähm, ja, ich kann dir erzählen, wie es ist, bei einem Dienstleister zu arbeiten,
weil ich habe meine Ausbildung bei einem Internet-Provider bzw. bei einem Dienstleister für Netzwerkservices und Virtualisierungsservices und Geschiss gemacht.
Aber damals gab es noch keine Azure.
Cloud und sowas.
Tja, und was kann ich dir sagen?
Also ich kann dir sagen, der Laden war scheiße.
Das lag aber nicht daran, weil es ein Dienstleister war.
Das lag daran, weil der scheiße geführt war.
Habe ich ja genug Videos drüber gemacht, dass ich auf die nicht so gut zu sprechen war, muss man sagen, weil der Laden ist mittlerweile pleite.
Ansonsten war es für mich eigentlich nur von Vorteil, dass es ein Dienstleister war, bei dem ich gearbeitet habe,
weil die haben mich verschachert nach Frankfurt und, ähm, also nicht.
Es war keine Arbeit, äh, wie heißt das, keine, keine, ähm, Vermittlungsbude.
Ja, die haben uns, die haben uns quasi dorthin verkauft von, also, wir waren angestellt beim Provider und die haben halt das RZ-Management,
das Rechenzentrumsmanagement von dieser, von der Bank in Frankfurt damals gemacht.
Und deswegen war ich halt dann dort in Frankfurt und, ähm, deswegen konnte ich auch direkt bei der Bank in Frankfurt anfangen,
als ich gekündigt habe beim Provider damals.
Die kannten mich alle schon, ich kannte die auch schon.
Ich habe gesagt, Jungs, ich habe keinen Bock mehr auf den, auf, äh, meinen aktuellen Arbeitgeber, kann ich nicht direkt bei euch anfangen.
Ich mache auch genau das gleiche weiter.
Dann haben die gesagt, Max, weißt du was, komm zu uns, kriegst sogar mehr Geld und, äh, schick mal die Kündigung ab.
Dann bin ich zu denen gekommen, hab mehr Geld gekriegt und hab die Kündigung abgeschickt.
Ich komme aus Frankfurt, doch, doch, doch, ich, naja, nicht direkt aus Frankfurt, aber ziemlich nah an Frankfurt dran.
Also, ich bin geboren in Offenbach, ich wohne in Hanau und ich arbeite in Frankfurt.
Gleiche Ecke.
Da würde ich mich ja nicht drauf verlassen, nachts.
Ey, die Templates, die, die, die der Dienstleister generiert hat, sind komplett abartig, weil die haben die Temp, äh, die, die, die Templates nicht selbst gebaut.
Die haben die Templates selbst wiederum generiert mit irgendeinem Generator-Skript.
Die sehen aus wie Sau, kannst du, blickst du nicht durch.
Ja, kann man ja nicht, weil der Hersteller das updatet und neu liefert.
Also, man kann es ja noch nicht mal fixen.
Der Hersteller muss das fixen.
Was hältst du eigentlich von einem Thinkpad T480 für dir?
Ich weiß nicht, was da drin ist, aber die Thinkpads kann man in der Regel für, für Daily-Linux-Sysadmin-Business gut empfehlen.
Da kannst du dir entweder einen Arch-Linux draufhauen oder wenn es ein bisschen was Klassischeres sein soll, kannst du dir auch einen Mint, einen Ubuntu oder, oder meinetwegen auch einen SUSE oder irgendwas draufhauen, was offiziell bei euch auf der Arbeit benutzt werden darf.
Die Dinger funktionieren meistens komplett ohne jegliche Probleme unter Linux.
Also, ich hatte jahrelang beim alten Arbeitgeber nur HP, äh, ähm, nur IP.
Also, ich hatte jahrelang beim alten Arbeitgeber nur HP, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, ä
die Zabbix Hersteller, also Zabbix ist
so eine Monitoring
ein Enterprise Class
Open Source Network
Monitor, was auch immer sie selbst
sagen, Solution
wahrscheinlich, also Monitoring System
und
wenn man sich Videos von denen anguckt
die sprechen es immer
Zabbix aus, aber
teilweise so richtig
Zabbix
ich habe ein Video gesehen von einer, die hat
irgendwie die neue Zabbix Version gezeigt
und hat gesagt, the new Zabbix
und ich konnte mir das Video nicht angucken
wegen der Aussprache von Zabbix, Alter
Zabbix
und hat gesagt, oh
ich muss ausmachen
die sprechen in ihren, Zabbix spricht
in ihren eigenen Youtube Videos
das so eklig aus
und da sollte man eigentlich denken, die wissen
was sie machen, habt ihr das als Monitoring?
Ne, also
wir haben beim neuen Arbeitgeber nicht, beim alten
Arbeitgeber hatten wir Zabbix als
Monitoring jahrelang
das wurde aber immer weiter
out, out gefaced
ach ja, da gibt es auch eine lustige Geschichte
was ich jetzt noch, die ich jetzt noch gehört habe
und zwar, wir hatten lange Zeit Zabbix
beim alten Arbeitgeber zum Überwachen
von Netzwerkgeräten, von
Servern, von allem, von Infrastruktur
ja, und das wurde jetzt nach und
nach ersetzt, weil sie haben ein eigenes Team
aufgemacht, was übrigens eine sehr gute Entscheidung war
auch jetzt im Nachhinein betrachtet, sie haben
beim alten Arbeitgeber hatten sie ein neues Team
aufgemacht, die sich nur um
Monitoringbelange kümmern soll, das ist ja auch
wirklich ein komplexes Thema, wo man
durchaus mal 4, 5 Leute hinlocken kann
die sich damit beschäftigen
und das wurde nach und nach quasi dann
out gefaced bei uns, der Zabbix
und ersetzt durch eine
Mischung aus Prometheus,
Grafana und
ähm, tja, Alert Manager
und halt automatisch
irgendwie Ticket, Ticket generieren
daraus, war eigentlich nicht verkehrt
wie sie das gemacht haben
hatte seine Vorteile, also hatte viele Vorteile
gegenüber Zabbix, gerade was Langzeitmetricspeicherung
angeht, hatte aber auch ein bisschen
seine Nachteile, halt, dass es viel gestückelter
ist als Zabbix, Zabbix ist halt so eine komplett
zusammenhängende Monitoringlösung
zumindest
habe ich jetzt folgendes gehört
von meinem alten Arbeitgeber, jetzt nachdem sie
Zabbix abgeschafft haben, haben sie
ihren neuen Netzwerkdienstleister und
der möchte nur mit Zabbix arbeiten
und wenn wir keinen
eigenen Zabbix haben, wo wir den Zugriff drauf
geben könnten, dann bauen sie
ihren eigenen Zabbix auf und rechnen uns das
ab
ist auch geil, oder?
ja, good luck, have fun, alles zu outsourcen
erst abgeschafft und
jetzt gibt es wieder Zabbix
hast du Erfahrung mit Client-Server-Backups
im Enterprise-Umfeld?
als Client
ja, als Admin nicht
also ich kenne eigentlich bloß Tivoli
und das ist nix, was ich freiwillig
benutzen würde
die reden die ganze Zeit noch von
Bandlaufwerken und sowas
in dem
Kontext
also ich kenne im Enterprise-Umfeld nur
Tivoli, was Backups angeht
also für so wirklich Komplett-Backups
von Systemen und sowas
VM ist ja eher was für VMs
wobei, ne, nicht nur, kannst theoretisch
auch alles mögliche mit machen
VM kenne ich aber nur aus dem
VM-Umfeld
im Enterprise-Umfeld kenne ich tatsächlich
nur Tivoli, wo das
überall eingesetzt wurde
also ich kenne das von drei Arbeitgebern
scheinen im Enterprise-Umfeld beliebt zu sein
gerade wenn es in der Finanzbranche ist
und die genug Geld haben
aber alles, was ich davon gesehen habe
bisher ist eklig
die hätten 299 hinschreiben müssen
du meinst für
für die Par3-Head-Leute
Low-IQ-Checked aus
das da, und PDF
trau ich mich hier ein PDF aufzumachen
ja, okay
krass
Microsoft Word 2022
was du gepostet hast
ist das was, wo du dich bewerben willst
oder was besonders?
ja, das ist das, was du postest
oder was ist der Hintergrund
warum du das gepostet hast
also nur, dass ich so ein bisschen weiß
ist maximal doof
okay, gucken wir uns gleich an
nee, also
man kann als Web-Server ja
prinzipiell nehmen, was man will
also es ist egal, ob das
patchy ist, Nginx
ich persönlich mag Nginx
wobei es halt vermehrt so ist
heutzutage, dass die Anwendung
eigentlich selbst ihren Web-Server mitbringt
und man den eigentlichen Web-Server
davor
entweder gar nicht mehr hat
weil man einen extra Load-Balancer davor hat
beziehungsweise Reverse-Proxy davor hat
oder aber
auf dem Rechner, also auf dem Server selbst
nochmal vorgelagert
ein Web-Server ist, der allerdings auch nichts anderes
als, ja, Zertifikatshandling
und Reverse-Proxy macht
also die meisten Anwendungen bringen heute eigentlich
ihren Web-Server mit, ich würde sagen
die meisten Anwendungen außer PHP
oder, ich kenn mich
zu schlecht mit PHP aus
ich würde sagen, die meisten Anwendungen
beziehungsweise, also die meisten
Frameworks bringen ihren Web-Server mit, außer PHP
also Ruby bringt
Ruby on Rails bringt schon immer mit
äh
Spring Boot ist ein eigener
Web-Server
.NET bringt seinen eigenen Web-Server mit
Node.js bringt seinen eigenen
Web-Server mit
Go bringt seinen eigenen Web-Server, also Go
Backends bringt seinen, also eigentlich
bringt nahezu alles seinen eigenen Web-Server mit
das heißt im Endeffekt startest du die
Anwendung halt mit
du startest einfach nur die Anwendung
so, und dann lauscht die an einem Port und spricht
http, fertig
und das expost du ja normalerweise nicht
direkt ins Internet, sondern du hast
halt in irgendeiner Art und Weise einen Loadbalancer
Schrägstrich Reverse-Proxy davor
der zum Beispiel SSL
Zertifikatshandling macht und
wo du die Backends rausnehmen
kannst, wenn eines kaputt ist
oder im besten Fall sogar automatisch
rausgenommen wird oder das Loadbalancing
entscheidet anhand von
wie viele
Connections die Backends haben, wie ausgelastet
die Backends sind
und sowas, wie es verteilt wird, also
meistens hast du da eh noch was davor
und das kann durchaus ein Nginx sein, es kann auch
eine HA-Proxy sein oder irgendwas
aber Apache
sieht man halt da an der Stelle
tatsächlich dann relativ wenig
einfach aus dem Grund, weil Apache halt so
ein riesen komplexes Ding ist
klar, Nginx auch
aber ich find die Minimal-Nginx-Config
irgendwie eingänglicher als Apache
ich persönlich muss ja sagen, für kleine Sachen
schwör ich auf Kadi als Webserver
äh
weil
simpler
kann die Konfiguration echt nicht mehr werden
guck mal, ihr müsst euch
ihr müsst euch mal die
die Example-Config angucken
was sie irgendwie
hier nicht haben
Alter, wie blöd
möchte man eine Startseite machen
also ich mein, ja das ist alles
aber die meisten Leute benutzen das für SSL-Handling
also
du brauchst
using Kadi-File, okay
ja die
Beispiele sind ein bisschen blöd, aber du brauchst meistens
nur zwei, drei Zeilen
dann hast du einen
fertig aufgesetzten
Reverse-Proxy, der für dich HTTPS
Zertifikats-Handling
und sowas macht
ob das nicht so toll ist, skaliert oder nicht
kann ich jetzt nicht beurteilen
ich würde mal sagen, ob das skaliert
oder nicht, wird nicht
zwangsläufig an PHP oder
MySQL liegen, sondern an dem
wie du deine Anwendungen strukturierst
also du wirst
MySQL denke ich halbwegs gescheit skalieren können
gehe ich jetzt einfach mal von aus
wie gesagt, ihr wisst, dass
ich nicht der allergrößte Datenbank-Checker
bin, aber ich kenne zum Beispiel noch
die klassische Variante, wie man früher Datenbanken
skaliert hat, quasi ein Node
mit Write-Access und ganz viele quasi
Read-Only-Nodes, was für die meisten
Anwendungen vollkommen okay war
das war halt gleichzeitig
die Art und Weise, wie man Datenbanken skaliert hat
bzw. auch Datenbanken ein bisschen hochverfügbar
gemacht hat
mit neueren Datenbanken, die man
wie so CassandraDB
und sowas, die man verteilen kann in der Cloud
ist natürlich noch cooler, aber ich denke, man kann
MySQL auch sinnig skalieren, PHP
klar, hängt ein bisschen davon ab, wie man
das ganze programmiert, wenn man alles in eine
Anwendung reinhaut
die
nicht gescheit mehrfach gestartet werden kann
dann macht es sicherlich Probleme
wenn man das ein bisschen aufsplittet
also ich denke, im Endeffekt
hängt das nach wie vor
nicht so sehr an der Technologiekombination
wenn das jetzt
auch wenn diese Kombi für mich jetzt nicht
super krasses skalieren schreit
aber in Maßen
oder lässt sich das immer noch ganz gut skalieren
wenn man es gescheit macht, also ich würde nicht
sagen, das geht nicht, aber
es muss gescheit
gemacht sein, was so ziemlich auf
jede Anwendung eigentlich zutrifft
ist egal, ob das jetzt eine Node-GP
ist, eine Go oder eine .NET Anwendung
ist, das muss so gebaut sein
dass es sich gut skalieren lässt und
man kann jetzt auch nicht, das war oft genug betont
viele Sachen müssen
gar nicht bis zum Umkippen skaliert
werden können, also
es ist doch wirklich selten so
dass man die Anforderung hat
quasi
von 5 Instanzen auf 5000
drauf und runter skalieren zu können
dynamisch, so on the fly
mehrfach am Tag und sowas in der Richtung
es ist ja eigentlich, also
wenn man jetzt nicht gerade
Amazon ist
und das Frontend
bei irgendwie
zu unterschiedlichen Tageszeiten und
Länder, wo die Leute
einkaufen, also
ganz ehrlich
das was ich gesehen habe bisher
auch im Business Enterprise, Finanzbranche
und Umfeld, wie das da mit
Skalierung gehandhabt wird, ist doch
recht
konservativ
da stellst du mal ein
bei einem Kubernetes Cluster
wenn du Bock hast, kannst du auch
bis zu 5 Nodes
hochziehen und wenn du Bock hast
kannst du auch bis zu, keine Ahnung
10 Replikas starten davon
aber im Großen und Ganzen
so super dynamisch
skalierte Anwendungen
täglich
mehrfach
hab ich persönlich so
selten erlebt, also
deswegen schlussfolge ich da draus
jetzt einfach auch mal, dass das
seltener vorkommt als man vielleicht
in irgendwelchen Konferenztalks sieht
ich mein
wann hast du so einen Fall
ok, stell euch vor ihr betreibt
einen Shop und PewDiePie
gibt euch unverhofft einen Shoutout
für euren Shop, was auch immer
und ihr habt normalerweise 500 User
irgendwie
keine Ahnung
in der Stunde und dann habt ihr auf einmal
5 Millionen
dann wärs ganz gut wenn euer Shop
skalieren könnte, das kommt aber
wahrscheinlich recht selten vor
und man kann ja auch
seine Anwendung skalieren auf klassische
Art und Weise, also man muss ja nicht
alles in 1000 Microservices
aufspalten oder irgendwelche
Cloudfähigen Datenbanken nehmen
über die Welt verteilt und irgendwie
super krasse Sperenzchen da machen
bis zum gewissen Maße
kann man natürlich auch sehr schön
skalieren mit wir machen einfach fettere
Hardware hin
was eventuell sogar gar nicht ne blöde Idee
sein kann, weil es oftmals
einfacher ist was zu starten
oder halt ein Projekt anzufangen
wenn man nicht
von Anfang an erstmal
alles in 1000 Microservices
aufsplittet oder guckt
wie können wir das jetzt mit irgendeiner super
modernen Cloud Native
Datenbank Lösung machen, dass das alles schön
skaliert und wo packen wir noch
irgendwelche Memory Caches
hin, wo packen wir noch irgendwelche
Message Queues hin, sondern man baut
einfach ne klassische Anwendung, die das
macht was gemacht werden soll
einfach weil sich viel schneller
entwickeln lässt und dann startet
man guckt ob das überhaupt irgendjemand
benutzen will und fängt an
und lässt seine Leute ein bisschen Werbung für machen
und gerade am Anfang kann man auch
wunderbar skalieren mit
lasst uns mal
ne fettere Kiste hinstellen
lasst uns mal zwei fette Kisten hinstellen
lasst uns mal unseren Datenbank Cluster
erweitern, ja
der Trend geht auch wieder weg von Microservices
ja das liegt aber daran
weil die Leute immer allem hinterher rennen was Amazon
oder irgendwelche tollen
Konferenztalk Leute und Hype Leute
erzählen, der Trend geht
jetzt wieder weg
von Microservices, zumindest
im Kopf
der Leute, weil Amazon letztens
einen Blogartikel rausgehauen hat
dass sie selber für ihr Video Prime
Streaming weniger Microservices verwenden
die hatten da aber auch so ein
übertrieben abgedrehtes Microservices
Konstrukt, wo ich mir gedacht hab, Alter
da hättet ihr auch selbst auf die Idee kommen können
dass es keine gute Idee ist, quasi
gefühlt für jeden Video Frame
einen eigenen Container zu starten
die haben ja wirklich
ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob sie für jeden Video
Frame einen eigenen Container gestartet
haben, aber sie haben für jeden Video Stream
einen eigenen Container gestartet und sowas
ganz furchtbar abgedrehtes Zeug
wo man sich eigentlich beim Blick auf die Architektur
von Anfang an denken konnte, so
also ob das jetzt so eine schlaue Sache
ist, fraglich
gut, wenn ich das gesehen hätte und hätte mir
gedacht, das ist ne blöde Idee
nächstes was ich mir gedacht hätte ist, okay
das ist Amazon, die werden schon wissen
was sie machen, aber da sind wir wieder beim Punkt
auch Amazon kocht nur mit Wasser
aber für jeden
Video Stream und teilweise
eigene Frames, eigene Container starten
ja, natürlich, das skaliert
richtig krass, aber da hast du ja so viel
Overhead vom ganzen Container starten
und Content kopieren und sonst was
was auch keine allzu schlaue Idee ist
man muss, ganz ehrlich, lange Rede
kurzer Sinn, man muss einfach gucken
dass das unterm Strich für den Anwendungsfall
den man hat, passt
man macht sich vorher ein bisschen Gedanken drüber
wie man das, wie man das ganze so aufbaut
anstatt irgendwelche Hype-Technologien
zu verwenden, nur weil das irgendwie
auf irgendeiner Konferenz cool aussah
oder weil Microsoft da oder
Amazon oder wer auch immer
irgendeinen Blog Eintrag drüber verfasst hat
ja das ist genauso wie
soll man Sachen in Kubernetes laufen lassen oder nicht
also ich würde sagen, ja es ist ne gute Idee
prinzipiell, wenn
es halt zur Anwendung passt und dem was man machen will
wenn man nen Webshop betreiben will
für was weiß ich
für die Oma, die ab und zu mal
paar selbstgestrickte Sachen verkauft
dann muss das nicht auf dem Kubernetes Cluster laufen
ähm
es muss halt einfach
Sinn machen
für die Anwendung
oder für die Anwendungen oder für die Services
müsste man dann eigentlich sagen, die man anbieten will
es muss halt einfach passen
und die Anwendungen müssen
halt auch darauf ausgelegt sein
es bringt halt nix
wenn du jetzt ne Anwendung baust
die eigentlich gar nicht darauf ausgelegt ist
dass sie mehrfach gestartet werden kann
dann musst du die auch nicht auf Kubernetes laufen lassen
wenn du jetzt ne Anwendung hast
die laufen irgendwelche Datenbank-Logs
File-System-Logs
oder gar Sachen auf File-Shares
schreibt und
liest und loggt und sonst was
oder so Dinger die halt
teilweise Oldschool Anwendungen machen
da musst du die nicht in Kubernetes Cluster hauen
weil es bringt dir nix
wenn du die Anwendung dreifach
im Kubernetes Cluster laufen lässt
wenn das Ding quasi alle externe Ressourcen
wo es darauf zugreift immer exklusiv locken muss
das hat überhaupt keinen Sinn
und es macht auch keinen Sinn
wenn du sie nicht skalieren können möchtest
wenn du einfach nur sagst
ey ich will 3 Backend Instanzen haben
dann stell dir 3 VMs hin
und gut da bist du sogar
in der Cloud noch wahrscheinlich billiger bei
als im Kubernetes Cluster
nun ja, was sagst du zu Kubernetes und Datenbank
ich mag die Kombination nicht
ich hab letztens ein Video geguckt von jemand auf YouTube
der wollte einem
erzählen
dass Kubernetes der beste Weg ist
in der Cloud Datenbanken laufen zu lassen
ich bin zumindest bis jetzt noch
vielleicht werde ich ja mal irgendwie noch überzeugt davon
ich bin bis jetzt der Meinung
dass es in der Regel
keine allzu schlaue Idee ist
klassische relationale Datenbanken
in Kubernetes laufen zu lassen
es mag mit so Sachen
wie CassandraDB und solchen Sachen
vielleicht anders aussehen
da muss ich aber dazu sagen
aber ich meine CassandraDB
ist immerhin eine Datenbank
die eben darauf ausgelegt ist
quasi kontinentweit
weltweit in der Cloud verteilt zu werden
und synchron zu bleiben
also das würde sich eher dafür eignen
für klassische relationale Datenbanken
in Kubernetes
ich persönlich bin da überhaupt kein Fan von
du hast ja damit
also ich finde du hast damit nichts gewonnen
weil das Problem wie cluster ich die Datenbanken
hast du immer noch
also so wie du
also nur weil du jetzt ein Kubernetes Cluster hast
und da drinne 3 Postgres laufen lassen kannst
heißt das noch lange nicht
dass die sich irgendwie miteinander unterhalten
also ein Postgres Cluster musst du nach wie vor bauen
nur dass du da noch Kubernetes drunter hast
ja
und um deine Anwendung musst du dir auch Gedanken machen
also im Endeffekt
und du hast halt auch weitere Probleme mit
wo lasse ich Migrations laufen
wie mache ich das wenn ich mein Cluster upgradee
wie mache ich das wenn ich meine Anwendung
Rolling Updates mache
dass das mit dem Schema passt
das hast du auch wenn das extern läuft
ja also
ich bin der Meinung
dass Datenbanken in Kubernetes oftmals
wenn man nicht weiß was man macht
ja vielleicht weiß ich einfach nur nicht was ich mache
ich halte das für keine allzu gute Idee
denn es gibt eine viel bessere Alternative
gerade wenn man den Kubernetes Cluster
in der Cloud betreibt
was man nach Möglichkeit machen sollte
weil Kubernetes selbst managen
ist eigentlich so ein Ding
da hast du über kurz oder lang Probleme
ja aus
aus unterschiedlichsten Gründen
weil bei Kubernetes
der Fehler beziehungsweise die Probleme oftmals
im Detail stecken
Kubernetes an selbst ist ja nicht das was das kompliziert ist
das ganze Ökosystem drumherum
und die tausend Sachen die man
beachten muss und das rausfinden
wie ist jetzt für mich der beste Weg was zu machen
das ist ja eigentlich das komplizierte
und deswegen sollte man nach Möglichkeit
eh einen Managed Kubernetes benutzen
und wenn man einen Managed Kubernetes nutzt
dann ist die Chance dass der Cloud Anbieter
bei dem man ist eine Managed
Datenbank anbietet enorm hoch
es bieten eigentlich alle
die mir so einfallen Managed Datenbanken an
Azure, Google, Microsoft
ne Quatsch
Amazon, Google, Microsoft bieten Managed Datenbanken an
DigitalOcean
bietet Datenbanken an
wenn du jetzt natürlich ein bisschen runter gehst und sagst
hey gucken wir mal bei einfachen
Hosting Providern zum Beispiel
Hetzner die bieten
keine Managed Datenbanken an aber
Hetzner bietet auch kein Managed Kubernetes an
bei Hetzner kannst du dir mit ein paar Terraforms
Scripts von GitHub relativ einfach
Kubernetes Cluster bauen lassen
das ist dann aber kein Managed Kubernetes Cluster
musst dich selbst drum kümmern
du musst dich um deine Control Nodes selbst kümmern
du musst dich um deine Worker Nodes selbst kümmern
also ja es ist eigentlich nur ne Installer
Installer Hilfe
deswegen Datenbanken
Datenbanken Kubernetes bin ich kein Fan von
weil die einfachste Variante ist
einfach die Datenbanken benutzen
die der jeweilige Cloud Anbieter
zur Verfügung stellt und damit hat man
überhaupt keine Probleme
halt meistens
ein bisschen mehr als den Kram komplett selbst
zu betreiben weil ja gut die wollen auch was
verdienen aber die kümmern sich halt auch drum
dass das ordentlich geclustert ist ordentlich
gemanagt wird ordentlich geupdatet wird
sodass du möglichst wenig von mitkriegst
7LQRS
dankeschön für den Sub
Poggers Keksdose hat Glück gehabt
Pogs Subscription noch einer
The Orzelord hat jetzt einen gekriegt danke für die 2 Subs
ja also so
so sehe ich das
zum Thema skalieren und Datenbanken in der Cloud
und solche Geschichten
Moment ich bin ja übelst weit hinten dran
das ist SAP oder
SAP ist immer Pains Champ
ja IP Tables
juckt doch eh keinen so wirklich äh nicht IP Tables
IPv6 juckt doch eh im
Enterprise Umfeld keinen wirklich überlegt euch mal
ich glaub selbst riesen Seiten
wie Amazon sind nicht mal über IPv6
erreichbar ist Twitch mittlerweile über
IPv6 eigentlich erreichbar
das nimmt niemand ernst das ist so IP
IPv6 ist seit 15 Jahren sich am
durchsetzen
die einzigen die das abfuckt aktuell
sind Leute die kein Dual Stack mehr
bekommen bei eh Vodafone
zum Beispiel
die sind gefickt äh wobei die müssen
halt über so einen doofen DSLite Tunnel
was extrem sagt
ansonsten ihr kennt
meine Meinung was äh was
um IPv6
ähm
sich durchsetzen angeht
also das das was
ich mir dazu denke ist folgendes ich glaube
nicht das wir den Tag
erleben werden
das alles was jetzt
über IPv4 erreichbar ist
über IPv6 erreichbar sein wird
was ich mir persönlich
vorstellen könnte
und
ja wie wahrscheinlich das ist
müssen wir mal gucken aber was ich mir persönlich
vorstellen könnte ist
das wenn Google
Microsoft Amazon
und wenn die alle
nicht Probleme bekommen mit
IPv4
und IPv6 benötigen
würden
dass sie sich was eigenes
ausdenken ich weiß das
ist nicht so einfach
wie es sich jetzt anhört
du kannst nicht einfach mal einen Layer 3 Protokoll
easy ersetzen
ja das muss an sehr vielen Stellen unterstützt wird
unterstützt werden dass das funktioniert
ja vom vom Client über
über deine Anwendungen
von den ganzen
Instrumentierungen für alle Betriebssysteme
und sonst was deswegen habe ich ja persönlich
die Vermutung ich habe keine Ahnung wie
ja wie stichhaltig das ist
und wie wahrscheinlich das ist und wie
wie wirklich umsetzbar
das ist ich habe ich ein bisschen
tue ich mir ein bisschen schwer aber man hat
man hat es gesehen das wenn
die großen
IT Unternehmen dieser Welt
ja von Microsoft Facebook
sonst was wenn die anfangen gemeinsame
Sache zu machen
oder an irgendwelche gemeinsamen Sachen mitzuwirken
guckt euch mal Browser
Browser Entwicklung an zum Beispiel die
letzten Jahre gut das ist ja im Prinzip
Browser Entwicklung okay es
es gibt ja eigentlich nur zwei Browser
es gibt Firefox und es gibt Chrome
die ziehen ungefähr am gleichen Strang
und es gibt noch ich habe gehört es gibt
auch noch so was wie Webkit also quasi Safari
die aber hoffnungslos
quasi veraltet sind so wie
früher der Internet Explorer okay nicht so krass wie früher
der Internet Explorer aber wenn man sich mal die
Features anguckt die Chrome und Firefox
unterstützen was ist die Features die Safari
unterstützt da kannst du eigentlich nur mal eine Runde
kecken und das Ding wieder
runter schmeißen leider
ist halt unter iOS Safari
also Webkit
Webkit Safari der einzige Browser den es
gibt aber nicht mal lange nicht mal lange
jo
deswegen ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher wie
wie
wahrscheinlich das ist aber ich könnte
mir durchaus vorstellen also wenn
wenn wirklich Amazon
und Microsoft und Google und
die alle anfangen
am gleichen Strang
zu ziehen weil die sagen fuck Leute IPv6
ist für den Arsch
und wir brauchen aber mehr Adressen
wir kommen mit IPv4 partout nicht aus
selbst mit unseren
Milliarden die wir haben um noch irgendwelche Reste aufkaufen
zu können dass die
irgendeine ganz abartige
IPv4 Erweiterung bauen
so IPv4,5
so was in der Richtung
wo dann so ganz
komische Dinger gemacht werden wie zum Beispiel
ähm man
benutzt irgendwelche
undefinierten Bytes
im Header
und wenn
die
das dritte Byte gesetzt ist
an dieser Stelle nur
dann musst du in diesen Header gucken
und dann hast du noch 4 weitere Bytes
frei für zusätzliche Adressen
so ganz komisches Zeug
ja
dass man dann quasi IPv4
Adressen irgendwie so
in der Richtung schreiben würde
also das normale IPv4 Adresse
und dass man dann irgendwie sowas schreiben würde
irgendwie keine Ahnung
ey
so und das ist dann quasi
dass die dann irgendwie gucken okay das ist ja eigentlich
ein privates Netz aber
dass so und so viel der Byte ist auf
ist gesetzt und das in Kombination
bedeutet wir müssen noch die
anderen zwei Header Felder auswerten
oder sowas ganz ehrlich
die Chancen dafür
finde ich sind gar nicht so weit
also ich kann es schlecht einschätzen
ich bin nicht der Hardcore Netzwerk
Standard Kenner
aber die Sache ist halt
die
wenn Microsoft und Google und
Apple und Azure und
ganz Sachen da mit dabei sind
die haben doch alles in der Hand
die haben die Browser in der Hand
die haben die Betriebssysteme in der Hand
die haben die Clouds und die Serveranwendung in der Hand
die können das theoretisch machen
ja also
ich glaube nicht dass der Tag kommt
dass wir sagen ey IPv6
alles was jetzt über IPv4 erreichbar ist
ist jetzt über IPv6 erreichbar
und wenn die großen IT Konzerne damit Probleme haben
die großen IT
und viele den Druck dort spüren
ja bei Amazon bei Microsoft bei Facebook
bei Google bei allen
die denken sich irgendeinen Hack aus
der rückwärts kompatibel ist
zu IPv4
der es noch komplizierter machen wird aber
ich glaube nicht dass man
in den nächsten Jahren Luft verschafft
wie auch immer der aussehen wird
wir finden da schon irgendwas
du hast dir gerade mal Open VM Tools in Wayland angeschaut
ja das ist das sagt
die ganz ehrlich Wayland in Verbindung mit
VMs ist halt voll für den Arsch
was für mich dann halt
Wayland voll für den Arsch macht
weil ich benutze hauptsächlich Linux
in der VM
ja wie man hier sieht
ich bin erst wie bei der Zappix
alle wie weit bin ich denn im Chat hinten dran
das kann nicht ganz nice sein
aber ich kann mit PRTG nie zufrieden werden
weil es Windows Only ist
ja sehe ich auch so
ich hatte das ja auch mal eine Weile
bei mir daheim am Start
weil ich mir gedacht habe so was simples reicht doch
aber reicht doch nicht
für mich
das habe ich relativ schnell gemerkt
reines is up down Monitoring bringt mir daheim nichts
ich will auch mal wissen ey
wie sieht es mit der Festplatten Auslastung aus
für die Kiste
für die Kiste wo Videos drauf gespeichert werden oder
ich will auch mal wissen
wie war denn die CPU Auslastung heute Nacht
kannst du mit uptown kuba nicht machen
deswegen ich habe ein Zappix bei mir lokal
mit dem ich aber auch nicht wirklich happy bin
würdest du sagen Unternehmen sollen möglichst viel IT outsourcen
und eher selbst machen
also es gibt ja durchaus
Mittelwege die man nehmen kann
ich glaube das ist auch ganz sinnvoll
man muss nicht jeden Furz selber machen
outsourcen kann ja alles mögliche sein
es muss ja nicht automatisch gleich zu irgendwelchen
Indern die weder richtig deutsch noch englisch können
outgesourced werden
man kann vielleicht irgendwelche Dienstleister vor Ort nehmen
man kann sich vielleicht komplett was fertig einkaufen
man kann vielleicht im europäischen Ausland
irgendwas nehmen
man kann viel größere Unternehmen
irgendwelche Tochterfirmen die das nebenbei machen
also das macht
denke ich durchaus Sinn
man muss da aber einen sinnvollen Mittelweg finden
so dieses
alles oder nichts ist meistens keine gute Idee
amazing danke für den Zapp
war es bisher immer
das war ja meine Frage dazu
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das bei PHP immer noch so ist
ich habe die Performancesachen jetzt echt nicht mehr im Kopf
also ich kann dir sagen
das größte System was ich betreut habe
war für 50.000 Außendienstmitarbeiter
natürlich haben nicht immer rund um die Uhr
alle 50.000 Leute gearbeitet
aber
selbst wenn du davon ausgehst
dass nur die Hälfte der an dem Tag gearbeitet haben
war da trotzdem ein bisschen was los
ich kann dir beim Beispiel sagen
ich bin mir nicht sicher
ob das so ist
aber
ich habe die Monitorwand noch vor mir
also
die Traffic Einheiten
waren auf jeden Fall in Gigabyte
aber ich kann es dir aus dem Kopf
echt nicht mehr sagen
wieviel Traffic und Request das waren
ungefähr
30.000 die Sekunde
oder so
Request sagen ja auch nicht wirklich so viel aus
können ja auch
wenige Request sein
und
ich weiß nicht
ob das was resultiert an
Last auf irgendwelchen Datenbanken
und in der Anwendung oder irgendwelche Berechnungen
können viel sein
keine Ahnung
also ich kann dir sagen 50.000 Leute haben es täglich benutzt
ja
das stimmt
MySQL ist vollkommen in Ordnung
oder vielleicht macht man es ja auch schlicht und ergreifend
einfach falsch
ich meine wenn man eine Relationale Datenbank
so als Art Key-Value-Store benutzt
ja dann muss man sich nicht wundern wenn die Performance sagt
wobei
Postgres kann es ja mittlerweile
mit den passenden Extensions ganz gut
Postgres kann prinzipiell alles
also ich weiß eh nicht warum man noch eine andere Datenbank
als Postgres benutzen sollte
ich meine für solche klassische Aufgaben
wenn man sowas verteiltes wie Cassandra DB haben will
was sich weltweit in Sync hält
in irgendwelchen Cloud
Geschichten dann ist wieder was anderes
aber als normale Relationale Datenbank
verstehe ich nicht warum man nicht einfach
Postgres immer und für alles nimmt
ja
ok
jetzt muss ich mir mal die Stellenanzeige angucken
das erste was mir schon mal negativ auffällt
ich hab schon vergessen
wenn die Stellenanzeige geschickt ist
Silver du hast die Stellenanzeige geschickt
also das erste was mir schon mal auffällt
warum mal das in der Welt ist das Ding wieder
Microsoft Word Anzeige 2022 und 25
Alter
kann nicht mal ein PDF gescheit generieren
also was suchen sie denn
RARI Food International aus der Luft
vom Land aus dem Meer
IT System Administrator
suchen sie
das macht mich immer schon ein bisschen skeptisch
wenn sie das so allgemein
schreiben weil ich mein das heißt dann
im Endeffekt auch wieder
wieder einer für alles Windows
Linux
Drucker
Storage
Virtualisierung
ok schauen wir mal
ist ein Lebensmittel importiert frisch und tief
bla bla bla bla
wir sind stolz darauf dass wir
ca 50 Mitarbeiter
ok das ist aber so mittelständlich ist das ganze
250 Mitarbeiter
zur Unterstützung unseres IT Teams in Hamburg
suchen wir zum nächstmöglichen Zeitpunkt
einen IT System Administrator
zu deinen Aufgaben zählen
jetzt gehts los
Installation und Administration der Infrastruktur
im Microsoft Umfeld
das klingt nach
Active Directory und Windows Shit
NO
GOD
das wäre für mich schon ganz
grausam
Windows Active Directory
im Zweifelfall noch
Internet Information Server
Service
Server?
gut also
Admin im Microsoft Umfeld
ok sicherstellen das System
Verquügbarkeit und Behebung von
gut das ist ja
durchaus in Ordnung
Eskalation
von Supports an
Externe Dienstleister
Eskalation von Supports
an Externe Dienstleister
Hä?
Ich verstehe den Satz nicht
Eskalation von
Supports?
Welche Supports eskalierst du da?
Meinen die von Support Tickets?
Aber warum sollte man
Support Tickets an externe Dienstleister
eskalieren?
Meinen die man macht bei einem externen Dienstleister
Support Tickets auf?
So nach dem Motto
keine Ahnung unsere Klimaanlage ist kaputt
und man hat
einen Dienstleister der sich darum kümmert
und man macht ein Ticket beim Dienstleister auf
die Klimaanlage ist kaputt
Meinen die das damit?
Also ich verstehe den Satz nicht
der Satz ist aber bescheuert geschrieben
Zusammenarbeit mit Systemhäusern
ok ja
kann jetzt ja alle so nichts heißen
Verantwortung des Update und Patch Managements
sowie des Backup und Recovery Managements
ja ok
wenn man sie für selber zuständig ist sollte man die auch updaten und patchen
klingt ja sinnig
Optimierung bestehender
Optimierung bestehender sowie
konzeptionier...
was?
Optimierung bestehender
bestehender was?
Ach Systemlandschaften
Optimierung bestehender
sowie Konzeptionierung
und Umsetzung neuer Systeme
ich hab keine Ahnung von deutscher Grammatik
aber das ist doch nicht richtig geschrieben der Satz oder?
da fehlt doch hier irgendwie
ein Bindestrich oder ein Komma oder irgendwas
weil
ist das
wirklich richtig so?
ok also Optimierung
und
Optimierung bestehender
und Konzeption und Umsetzung neuer Systeme
ja ok passt auch
Verwaltung von Nutzern
Oh Active Directory
ich habs doch gesagt Leute
Nein Gott
bitte nein
Fick dich weg du Robofürst
das ist Windows und Active Directory
nee
Beschaffung, Test und Wartung von
Hardware und teilweise Software
Beschaffung
Gehen wir mal kurz
in Saturn und holen
ne USB Festplatte
ja gut die meinen bestellen bei irgendeinem Dienstag
dass du da mitmachst und so das ist ne kleine
ein kleinerer Laden
das klingt ja noch in Ordnung
Fachliche Begleitung von Projekten zur
Weiterentwicklung der IT Landschaft
ey du bist also quasi ansprechbar
ok
damit ist vorbei
damit ist die Sache gelaufen
also ich hätte ja
bis hier hin
also diese Sachen die ich hier
markiert hab das hätte ich ja noch
mit nem Auge zugedrückt
hätte ich gesagt ok
das ist vielleicht nicht sonderlich optimal
aber es ist ein kleiner Laden
und
ja das passt noch
irgendwie aber spätestens
wenn die alle Support der Anwender
nee
da wäre für mich komplett vorbei
die suchen seit
Mitte 2022
ja gut warum wohl ne
warum suchen die wohl seit so einem Jahr schon
die suchen seit genau einem Jahr
ok
es geht noch weiter heißt es
gucken wir mal weiter
du passt zu uns
wenn du
eine Ausbildung zum Fachinformatiker für Systemintegration
oder vergleichbare Ausbildung
mit 4 bis
4 bis
10 Jahren Berufserfahrung
jetzt
also
was ist wenn ich 11 Jahre Berufserfahrung habe
entweder schreibst du
4 Jahre
also
entweder
3 Jahre
oder 4 Jahre
oder
also
so
aber
ist
es
das
hier
ist
hat ist dieses bild hier oben drin ok ich meine entweder schreibt man mit vier jahren oder mit
mindestens vier plus jahren oder wie auch immer berufserfahrung aber warum schreibt man dann vier
bis zehn also ich meine was ist wenn ich elf habe oder drei mal okay drei kommt man sagen
es zu wenig ist aber aber überhaupt ich meine warum warum warum überhaupt vier ich meine dass
da oben sieht das nicht so nicht sonderlich advanced aus muss ich sagen advanced macht
wahrscheinlich macht wahrscheinlich der laden drumherum es ist halt ziemlich viel gemixt und
support für den anwender ist halt auch komplett komplett für einen arsch ja ok du meinst einer
mit elf jahren hatte keinen bock fürs gehalt das zumal okay das kann natürlich sein
ja ok du meinst einer mit elf jahren hatte keinen bock fürs gehalt das zumal ok das kann natürlich sein
naja er finde ich aber trotzdem ein bisschen komisch geschrieben ganz ehrlich den wird auch
jemand reichen der frisch mit der ausbildung fertig ist oder vielleicht ein jahr berufserfahrung hat
und sich halt im windows ad bereich ausgehen die wollen die wollen den windows admin der
ad ahnung hat das ist das ist das was die im kern wollen im kern wollen den windows admin
der sich mit active directory auskennt soweit alles andere wo macht man wann wenn
sich stellt
google
Dass du neben deinem Windows-Krempel natürlich noch alles netzwerkmäßig mitmachen musst, war ja logisch, war ja zu erwarten, war ja zu erwarten, ja.
Fundierte Erfahrung mit Microsoft SQL, RDS, meinen die Datenbanken? Also, relationale Datenbanken, oder was meinen die da? Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Microsoft Server SQL, oder wie manche sagen würden, SQL, Exchange, MonkaS, Power, ClientOS, okay, was zum Teufel ist ClientOS?
Ach, ich dachte, das ist, ich meine, was ein ClientOS ist, ist mir klar, also ein ClientOS, wahrscheinlich, was die Windows-Anwender auf ihren Rechtern haben, aber ich dachte, es gibt irgendein Produkt, was sich ClientOS nennt, oder sowas.
Dich mit Virtualisierung speziell vor MWR auskennen, ach, das auch noch, ah ja, du machst Netzwerk, du machst Windows Active Directory, Endanwender-Support, Hardware-Software-Bestellung,
aber das bei Projekten.
Mit Projekten mit, und machst nebenbei noch Virtualisierung, Netzwerk und Exchange und sowas, klar, einen proaktiven, selbstständigen, verantwortungsvollen Arbeitsstil und schnelle Auffassungsgabe hast.
Ich finde es immer komisch, wenn die Leute sowas in die Bewerbung schreiben, weil, jetzt mal ehrlich, jetzt mal ehrlich, gibt es irgendjemand, der sich dort bewirbt,
und im Vorstellungsgespräch dann sagt, so, ah, übrigens, also meine proaktive, selbstständige, verantwortungsvolle Arbeitsstil und schnelle Auffassungsgabe habe ich nicht.
Oder der dann sagt, ah, nee, dann bewerbe ich mich nicht, wenn alles andere passiert.
Irgendwie, das ist so vollkommen redundant, dass jemand, der in der IT arbeitet, ein bisschen was im Hirn haben muss.
Ja, okay, aber ich finde es komplett überflüssig, das reinzuschreiben, weil ernsthaft, wenn sich irgendwie der übelste,
P-Pega-Threehead-Typ da bewirbt, dann stellst du halt nicht ein.
Das kannst du doch eh im Vorfeld null drauf geben.
Niemand würde sich deswegen dort nicht bewerben.
Niemand denkt von sich, alter, ich bin nicht proaktiv, selbstständig und verantwortungsvoll genug, ich bewerbe mich da nicht.
Ja, das kannst du überall reinschreiben und dadurch, dass du es überall reinschreiben kannst, kannst du es auch überall rauslassen.
Chico, was ist los? Die Katze ist bei mir an der Tür.
Katze ist am Start.
Ist reingeflitzt hier ins Arbeitszimmer.
Und sitzt jetzt auf dem Schrank und guckt mich an.
Und jetzt?
Ja, Chico, was jetzt?
Ich habe keine Leckerlis.
Die sitzt jetzt oben auf dem Schrank und will Knuspelecken oder irgendwie sowas haben.
Gibt es jetzt nicht?
Du musst nicht gucken.
Ich gucke dir jetzt einfach nicht weiter an.
Okay, also weiter.
Kommunikation sowie hohe Kunden- und Serviceorientierung.
Dieses Bla-Bla, das kannst du einfach komplett weglassen.
Also es würde niemand davon abhalten.
Sich zu bewerben und umgedreht würde auch niemand sagen, nee, das habe ich nicht.
Also kannst du eigentlich komplett rauslassen, diese Sprüche.
Auch mal mit anpacken kannst.
Ja gut, die bestellte Hardware muss natürlich auch hochgetragen werden.
Ist schon logisch.
Reise...
Alter, die wollen auch jetzt...
Sag mal, kann das sein?
Ich glaube, ich habe ein System entdeckt, Leute.
In dieser Stellenbeschreibung.
Die beschissensten Sachen stehen immer im letzten Punkt.
Hier oben steht...
Alles soweit okay.
Support für den Endanwender.
Hier soweit würde ich sagen, zwar ziemlich pepega, aber irgendwie ja passt und als Ende kommt Reisebereitschaft.
Ich meine, Reisebereitschaft und Support für den Anwender, das ist ja in Kombination schon mal komplettes K.O.-Kriterium.
Deswegen bewirbt sich dabei wahrscheinlich auch keiner.
Also keiner, der irgendwie von den anderen Sachen eine Ahnung hat.
Und wahrscheinlich bist du dann auch der einzige IT-Typ, den sie haben.
Wir bieten dir einen Arbeitsplatz, an dem du tatsächlich gefordert wirst, der dir ausreichend möglich ist.
Möglichkeiten bietet sich selbst.
Hat irgendjemand schon mal gedacht...
Ich meine, ich kenne das, da schreiben viele rein.
Aber habt ihr schon mal gedacht, wenn ihr nach Bewerbungen guckt und euch so fragt...
Wie würde für mich dann ein guter Arbeitsplatz aussehen?
Ist das das Erste, an was ihr denkt?
Ja, ich suche einen Arbeitsplatz, an dem du tatsächlich gefordert wirst und dir ausreichend Möglichkeit bietet, dich selbst weiterzuentwickeln.
Ja, in gewisser Weise spielt das sicherlich mit Reisebereitschaft.
Nein, aber nicht so in dieser Art und Weise, wie sie es schreiben.
Also ich wähle einen Arbeitsplatz, wo es mich interessiert, die Themen, die da gemacht werden.
Und ja, natürlich will ich auch irgendwie Möglichkeiten haben, mal was Neues zu machen, was anderes zu machen.
Aber wahrscheinlich habe ich da eine komplett andere Vorstellung als die, die den Satz geschrieben haben.
Eine leistungsgerechte Vergütung.
Im Ernst, wahrscheinlich bezahlen die 40k im Jahr oder sowas.
Eine Unternehmenskultur, die Freiräume bietet.
Verantwortung.
Überträgt und auch partnerschaftlich.
Ja, das könnt ihr alle sagen.
Das sagen ja auch alle so bla bla im Endeffekt.
Da kann man halt nichts drauf geben.
Flache Hierarchien und offene Türen, denn Initiativen sind eventuell.
Sagen auch alle.
Ob es das wirklich so machen, wirst du erst erfahren, wenn du da bist.
Was ist ein angemessenes Gehalt nach der Ausbildung?
Ausbildung als was?
Eine reizvolle Tätigkeit in kleinen Teams mit offener Kultur.
Das ist auch so furchtbar nichtssagend.
Also ich finde beispielsweise Support für den Endanwender nicht sonderlich reizvolle Tätigkeit.
Fachinformatiker.
Ja, schwer zu sagen.
Es hängt natürlich ein bisschen davon ab, in welcher Branche, vor allem in welchem Bundesland, in welchem Gebiet.
Also ich kann nicht sagen, was ich bekommen habe.
Ich kann nur sagen, ich habe direkt nach der Ausbildung 33.500 bekommen damals.
Vor 15 Jahren oder so beim Provider noch.
Naja, nee, nee, nicht 15 Jahre.
Auf.
Ohne Scheiß.
Mittlerweile wirklich fast 15 Jahre.
Und mir kommt es vor, als wäre es gestern gewesen.
Ohne Scheiß.
Krass, oder?
Krasser Scheiß.
Das kommt mir alles nicht so lange vor.
Naja, gut.
Also ich habe damals 33.500 bekommen.
Wenn du da jetzt die Inflation und sonst was reinrechnest, würde ich mal sagen, also unter 40k eher nicht.
Oder Chat, was sagt ihr dazu?
Es kommt aber, wie gesagt, sehr stark auf Branche und vor allem Region an.
Also unter 40k würde ich es auf keinen Fall machen.
Vielleicht sollte man eher Richtung 45k mittlerweile sogar schon zielen.
Das kann ich aber schwer einschätzen.
Wie gesagt, es kommt sehr auf Branche und vor allem halt auch auf die Region an, wo du bist.
Siehst du, in München.
Ja gut, München.
Deswegen, ich glaube, 45 ist durchaus drin.
Wie gesagt, es kommt auf die Region und auch die Branche an.
Finanzbranche bezahlt sehr gut.
Versicherungsbranche bezahlt sehr gut.
Pharmaindustrie bezahlt sehr gut.
Ja, das sind die drei, wo ich weiß, dass ich gut bezahle.
So, also.
Wenn wir dein Interesse geweckt haben, überzeugt uns.
Also, mich würde das Interesse tatsächlich wecken, wenn sie wenigstens ihre Wörtervorlage ordentlich im...
Nein, das Interesse würde mich ehrlich gesagt nie wecken.
Aber sie hätten ja wenigstens ihre Wörtervorlage und Zeilenränder irgendwie im Griff haben können.
Bewerbung.
Ja, nice.
Okay, da weiß ich schon mal, wo ich mich nicht bewerbe.
Ich bewerbe mich generell nicht.
Nur für den Fall der Fälle, dass wieder einer fragt, Max, suchst du schon wieder einen neuen Job?
Nein, nein, ich suche keinen neuen Job.
Ich bin eigentlich jetzt...
Ich bin zwei Monate...
Ich bin zwei Monate dort beim neuen Arbeitgeber und bis jetzt eigentlich auch ganz happy beim neuen Arbeitgeber.
Ich werde jetzt erstmal bleiben.
Siehe deinen Spoiler zu der Anzeige.
Kommt der hier noch im Chat?
Oder habe ich den schon überscrollt?
Hopp, ne?
Ja, gehe ich auch von aus, dass viele nicht über IPv6 erreichbar sind.
So, dann mal eine Public IPv4 bekommen.
Das ist alles okay.
Was kommt zuerst?
IPv6, Flächendenken oder das...
Ja, das Dienungsnetz.
Ja, ich glaube, das kommt alles ziemlich zeitgleich.
Ich konnte noch fragen, ob Elder Scrolls 6 vielleicht vorher rauskommt oder Half-Life 3.
Also, wenn ihr mich fragen würdet, was setzt sich zuerst durch oder was kommt zuerst?
IPv6?
Also, muss ich anders formulieren.
Half-Life 3 oder dass alles, was jetzt über IPv4 erreichbar ist, über IPv6 erreichbar sein wird.
Dann sage ich, Half-Life 3 kommt zuerst.
Eindeutig.
Für Half-Life 3 gibt es ja in irgendeiner Art und Weise noch eine, naja, semi-realistische Chance.
Die Half-Life-Games waren immer super erfolgreich.
Und vielleicht haben sie...
Hat Gaben doch noch irgendwann mal Bock.
Und IPv6 wird sich halt flächendenken, dass alles, was jetzt IPv4, dann IPv6 verfügbar ist, wird halt nie passieren.
Finde ich auch eine gute Idee, mit IPv6-Only-Servern anzufangen.
Weißt du, was ich noch viel besser bei Hetzner finde?
Server komplett ohne Public-IP.
Das ging ja auch eine ganze Weile nicht.
Was ich ziemlich bescheuert fand...
Was sag ich, das Icon da vorne?
Ah, TwitchCon.
Was ich ziemlich bescheuert fand, weil...
Es brauchen gar nicht alle Server Public-IPs.
Die wenigsten Systeme in der Cloud-Infrastruktur brauchen Public-IPs.
Public-IPs brauchen eigentlich nur die Eingänge oder vielleicht noch irgendwelche VPN-Endpunkte.
Oder irgendwelche Jump-Hosts.
Aber ansonsten braucht eigentlich nix externe IPs.
Was ist besser, IPv6 und was ist der Unterschied zwischen IPv4?
Was besser ist und was der Unterschied ist, kann man relativ einfach erklären.
Es gibt sehr viele Unterschiede.
IPv6 ist ein komplett neues Protokoll.
Auch mit ganz vielen neuen Feinheiten.
Der hauptsächliche Unterschied ist, du hast mehr Adressen zur Verfügung mit IPv6.
Also nicht nur ein bisschen mehr, sondern irgendwie...
Einmal alle Atome im Universum mehr irgendwie.
Es ist unglaublich viel mehr, was du zur Verfügung hast bei IPv6.
Und...
Ja, das ist eigentlich auch der einzige...
Naja, nee, das stimmt nicht.
Das kann man so nicht sagen.
IPv6 hat noch ein paar andere coole Sachen.
Zum Beispiel...
Dass sie Native IPsec-Unterstützung haben.
Und es gibt noch mehr.
Müsste ich nachgucken.
Ich mache ehrlich gesagt noch zu wenig...
Also ich mache relativ wenig.
Oder relativ selten was mit IPv6.
Einfach weil es nicht so wirklich relevant ist.
Auch wenn das viele Netzwerker nicht gerne hören.
Ja.
An das Trinken erinnern.
Sehr gute Idee.
Exzellent.
Hast du das...
Nein.
Was ist da?
Habe ich nicht mitbekommen.
Haben sie abgeschaltet, oder?
Leute, ich habe es doch letztens gesagt.
Wir hatten doch genau dieses Thema letztens im Stream.
Und da habe ich gesagt, mich wundert es...
Weil die Leute gesagt haben, benutzt doch einfach Apollo.
Mich wundert es...
Dass die das überhaupt noch anbieten können, jetzt nachdem Reddit mit ihrer API und Geschiss angekommen ist.
Und zack.
Bam.
Haben wir es mal wieder prediktet im Stream.
Äh, habe ich...
Silver, habe ich irgendwo dein Kram überlesen?
Stellenbeschreibung.
Da war noch nichts, oder?
Der kommt noch, okay.
Meine Firma bezahlt mir vielleicht eine Einführung in Linux. Kennst du einen guten Kurs oder ähnliches?
Irgendwann...
Ne.
Dafür mache ich das schon zu lange. Keine Ahnung, was ein guter Einsteigerkurs ist.
Oder wer sowas anbietet.
Äh, das sind 50 Mitarbeiter. Was erwartest du, dass sie ein ganzes IT-Team haben?
Ja.
Weil das eine der wichtigsten Sachen für die ganze Firma wahrscheinlich ist.
Also ich meine, ein Team kann ja auch durchaus mal 3, 4, 5 Leute sein.
Ja.
Würde ich erwarten.
Wenn ihnen das wichtig ist.
Gerade in der heutigen Zeit.
Da kann man sich nämlich auch darauf verlassen, dass es gescheit gemacht wird.
Ja, ich meine, wir haben auch alle 20 Jahre Kubernetes-Erfahrung, oder?
Ähm, ja.
Sophie, Gabby... Ne, Quatsch.
Ähm, das ist ja...
Das ist einfach nur...
Einfach nur Hex hier an der Stelle.
Ich habe Sophie gelesen gerade.
Ja, also ich...
Das denke ich auch an der Stelle.
Ach, RDS ist Remote Desktop Services.
Okay, das passt auch besser in Windows-Geschiss rein.
Ist ja fast normal, wenn die Personalabteilung das schreibt.
Vor allem, wenn die Personalabteilung das schreibt.
Nicht in engerer Zusammenarbeit mit dem Team, was eigentlich die Leute sucht.
Tja.
Was sollen sie machen?
Was sollen sie denn machen?
Ich meine, ja, du hast schon in gewisser Weise recht.
Also viele finden nichts.
Und viele bewerben sich auch schon gar nicht mehr direkt.
Sondern lassen sich erstmal anschreiben und bewerben sich dann.
Aber was sollen sie machen?
Ich meine, wenn die Leute suchen, können sie ja nicht sagen,
ah ja, gut, wir ergeben uns und leben einfach damit.
Gut, im Endeffekt müssen sie sich auch nicht mehr direkt bewerben.
Müssen sie damit leben, weil sie niemanden mehr finden.
Aber die müssten im Prinzip schon ein bisschen das machen, was du sagst.
Sie müssten woanders aktiv werden.
Sie müssten zum Beispiel aktiv zeigen, dass sie ein guter Arbeitgeber sind.
Und zum Beispiel Leute, die eh schon innerlich keinen Bock mehr auf ihren aktuellen Job haben,
aber noch nicht richtig suchen, versuchen anzusprechen.
Was nicht so einfach ist.
Gerade wenn du so eine kleine 50-Mann-Firma bist,
stelle ich mir das schwierig vor,
dann müsstest du das nicht machen.
Dann müsstest du das von irgendwelchen Headhunter-Typen machen lassen,
die wahrscheinlich einfach nur Geld kosten und für den Laden auch keinen finden.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Ich bin froh, dass ich nicht dort in der Personalabteilung arbeite und dafür zuständig bin.
Die haben es sicherlich nicht einfach gerade.
Spoiler!
Der jetzige Admin hat einen Windows-Client mit 3389 Internet-Express.
Ist das der jetzige Admin, dessen Chef,
also der entschieden hat,
also für den jetzt die Erstellen-Anzeige ersetzt,
der jetzt ersetzt werden soll mit der Stellen-Anzeige, oder?
Es ist eine blöde Idee, Windows per LDP ins Internet zu hauen.
Das hat er wahrscheinlich gemacht, dass er von unterwegs darauf zugreifen kann,
weil die Firma nicht in der Lage war, ihm gescheite Remote-Arbeitsmöglichkeiten zu bieten.
Meistens hat er sowas einen Grund und der Grund ist,
öfters,
also ne, muss ich anders sagen,
der Grund, warum sowas gemacht wird, ist oftmals nicht die Unfähigkeit der Admin-Leute, sondern irgendwelche
Randbedingungen, die sie dazu veranlassen, das zu machen.
Ich hab grad getrunken.
Ah, jetzt will Chico wieder raus.
Ja, Mensch, Chico, jetzt mach mal vor, ey.
So, also, wie gesagt, Leute, ich muss, muss gleich ins Bett.
Bett getimed.
Ich mein, 22.10, ihr wisst, was jetzt ist, oder?
Was ist jetzt? Wer weiß es?
22 Uhr.
Lukas, danke für den Sub.
Ey, kannst du, äh, gut, das hatten wir ja gerade schon.
Das hatten wir ja gerade schon.
Ach nee, Moment, das ist was anderes.
Was ein gutes Gehalt für die Stelle wert.
Du meinst für die Stellenanzeige, die wir uns eben angeguckt haben?
Also, ganz ehrlich, dass ich den Mist mache,
also, zumindest auch, vor allem, das, was ich jetzt schon so mir vorstellen kann, wie mistig das sein wird,
da müssten wir dir, die müssten mir 250k im Jahr bezahlen, wenn ich's machen würde.
Das, das kann einfach nur frustrierend und ätzend werden.
Das würde ich nicht machen.
Also, die müssten mir wirklich richtig Schmerzensgeld bezahlen dafür.
Also, für so eine Viertelmillion im Jahr würde ich's machen.
Was sie selbstverständlich nicht bezahlt.
Für alles andere im Leben nicht.
Realistischer betrachtet, ich geh davon aus, die bezahlen dir 40, 45k.
Das ist wahrscheinlich auch so ein Laden, die für ihre IT-Leute nicht viel Geld ausgeben wollen.
Also, mach, komm bloß nicht auf die Idee, dich bei sowas zu bewerben.
Also, ich glaube, da machst du dir nur das Leben schwer mit.
2,3 in der Abschlussprüfung ist nice, das ist ein ziemlich gutes Ergebnis.
Also, viele sind, äh, diesmal wohl, hab ich, hab ich gelesen, weiß nicht, ob's wirklich stimmt.
Ja.
Sogar eine im Chat geschrieben.
Viele sind diesmal deutlich schlechter in der Abschlussprüfung.
Und Hauptsache, du hast bestanden.
Eigentlich ist es egal.
Aber 2,3 ist doch wirklich gut.
Also, nicht nur wirklich gut, auch praktisch in Worten gut.
Das ist immer noch da.
Aber ich hab ne Linux-VM, auf der ich root bin.
Einzige, was ich auf meinem Windows-Notebook laufen hab, ist Terminal im Fullscreen.
Also, eigentlich Riftless Studio Code, und darin ist Terminal im Fullscreen.
Ja, das bei AWI, das geht bei fast allen, aber bei vielen Hosting-Anbietern geht's nicht.
So, bei reinen Hosting-Anbietern.
Also, bei Hexner geht's beispielsweise noch gar nicht lang, dass du Server komplett ohne
Public-IP oder jetzt halt auch zumindest mal ohne IPv4 buchen kannst.
Es ist, es ist aber ein guter Trend, weil, wie gesagt, wenn man ein bisschen, wenn man
ein bisschen größere Infra-, ein bisschen umfangreichere Infrastruktur in der Cloud laufen
hat, oder halt auch bei irgendwelchen Hosting-Anbietern laufen hat, die meisten Kisten brauchen keine
Public-IP.
Wozu?
Solange die intern verbind-, verbunden werden können.
Du, du brauchst deinen Eingang, brauchende, also deinen Loadbalancer, beziehungsweise
den Reverse Proxy-Wan, Public-IP, und vielleicht irgendwelche, ähm, Admin-Geschichten brauchen
auch Public-IP, wo du dann da drüber reinkommst, oder VPN-Endpunkte oder so, ansonsten braucht
halt nix Public-IPs.
Das stimmt.
Wobei man ja auch argumentieren könnte, dass NAT, und ich weiß, da schreien jetzt die
ganzen IPv6-Fans.
Aber ich finde, es ist, es ist, es ist, es ist, es ist, es ist, es ist, es ist, es ist,
es ist, trotzdem so.
NAT automatisch ein Schutz davor ist, dass du nicht aus Versehen Dinger freigibst, die
du nicht freigeben willst.
Ja, natürlich, ne, kommen jetzt die Leute und sagt ja, aber NAT, du, so ein Firewall
mit IPv6.
Aber bei NAT ist es halt einfach vom Prinzip her ausgeschlossen, dass du was freigeben
kannst.
Du kannst mit NAT nichts freigeben, was du nicht, also, selbst wenn du willst, kannst
du mit NAT nicht wirklich alles freigeben.
Da hast du recht Schildfreak.
Das wirds' schon auch geben.
Ah ich danne einfach etwas.
Nicht mehr.
selling.
technちп
eine Frage bezüglich Nasse-Malbetrieb. Ich habe
ein Synology DS216
Jo, okay, was auch immer das für eins ist.
So, so
wolltest du das.
Aber es ist sicherlich legal erworben
und von deinem Datenträger ohne Umgehung
des Kopierschutzes gerippt,
oder? Aber der Plex
meint, dieser ist aber nicht leistungsfähig genug.
Keine Ahnung, ich habe von Plex
keinen Schimmer. Also wenn du
transcoden willst, und das ist wahrscheinlich das Problem,
wenn du transcoden willst,
ja, das braucht
Fettleistung, gerade wenn es 4K ist.
Also wenn du keine Möglichkeit
hast, den Hardware zu transcoden,
braucht das extremst CPU-Last.
H265
oder H264
wahrscheinlich meistens H264
4K transcoden on the fly?
Da kannst du
mal locker,
naja, wenn du aktuell, mal angenommen,
du hast eine aktuelle 8-Kern-CPU,
wobei, dann hast du auch in irgendeiner Art
und Weise
Hardware-Decoding.
Also wenn das Ding
kein Hardware-Decoding hat,
und das ist komplett CPU-technisch
am Anschlag, wenn du transcoden willst,
4K on the fly transcoden,
H264, kannst du komplett
klicken, wobei ich es nicht weiß,
wie gut das ausgestattet ist.
Wenn du einfach nur streamen willst,
ohne transcoden,
was aber halt voraussetzt, dass
dein Client das Format kann,
in dem gestreamt wird,
dann sollte das gehen, aber,
ja, keine Ahnung, von Plex und auch nicht,
was Plex mit der, also ich kenne die Hardware nicht,
ich hab von Plex keine Ahnung, ich weiß auch nicht, was Plex
mit der Meldung sagen will.
Ja.
Ist doch nicht verkehrt, wenn die erstmal checken, ob ihre
Mitarbeiter geistig irgendwie
halbwegs kompatibel sind.
Ich mein, je nachdem, was da gefragt wird, kann das auch
ausarten, ja.
An Twitch mittlerweile AV1,
keine Ahnung.
Zucker, danke für den Sub. Ja, wie gesagt,
GZ.
Meine Firma, wo ich meine Physi-Ausbildung
erst nach dem Anfang, Dinger mit
geografischen Formations- und
Betriebsinformationssystemen, dir
das zu... Nö.
Nee. Aber da kannst du einfach mal nachgoogeln,
was die Firma macht, die haben doch bestimmt eine Webseite.
Wahrscheinlich ist es
einfacher, auf der Webseite von der Firma zu gucken,
anstatt mich zu fragen, ob ich
weiß, was es ist, oder?
Und ansonsten, keine Ahnung,
was das sein soll. Ich mein,
geografische Informationssysteme, das kann alles
Mögliche sein. Die könnten auch
irgendwelche LoRa-Sensoren für Bauern
herstellen, dass sie die
Wässerung ihrer Kornfelder
überwachen können. Du meinst,
wie heißt das, UPnP und so
Geschiss, ne? UPnP
geht aber nur, wenn der Client das auch kann, und
wenn der Router das kann. Das würde ich eh prinzipiell
ausschalten. UPnP ist Shit.
Und ansonsten, was du machen kannst,
was aber mit nahezu allen,
also,
was mit jeder NAT-Lösung
funktioniert, ist
diese
NAT-Hole-Geschichte, wo du
einen externen Server aufbaust,
deine Informationen weitergibst an den
anderen, der sich verbindet, und der dann quasi
als
Absender so tut.
Ich krieg das mit diesem
NAT-Hole-Punching gerade im Kopf nicht
zusammen. Das geht aber
prinzipiell immer.
Besser ein paar Ausnahmen.
Aber zumindest,
diese UPnP-Geschichte geht nur, wenn der Router
das kann, und wenn der Client das kann.
Okay, wenn's ein Celeron ist, hast du eh geschissen.
Dann ist da mit großartigem Streaming wahrscheinlich
nix. So, Leute,
ich hab's geschafft. Schön, dass ihr dabei
gewesen seid. Jetzt ist Bad-Getime.
Bis dann, macht's gut.
See you. Was?
Preise sinken weiter.
Sehr gut. Vielleicht sind's ja irgendwann
mal wieder auf dem, wofür man sich
Raspberry Pis kaufen kann.
Bis dann, macht's gut. See you.
Ja, Tima, du bist zu spät. See you.